AND I LIKE TO START OFF BY
THANKING SEE FOR A FOR HOSTING
ANOTHER ONE OF OUR COMMITTEE
HERE HERE IS AT YOUR ANNUAL
CONFERENCE --
AND WHEN FOLKS SAID FOLKS AS TO
WHY YOU DOING HEARING THE DAY
AFTER ELECTION MICHAEL C. FORAYS
MEETING IN THE ROAD I DO HERE
AND WE NEED TO DO IT.
WAS THE FOR A BECAUSE THAT'S
WHERE THE PEOPLE THAT ACTUALLY
ARE DOING THE WORK ARE GOING TO
BE -- AND SO
WE WERE JUST HERE LAST YEAR
DISCUSS THE IMPACT OF FEDERAL
CUTS ON CALIFORNIA SENIORS WERE
STILL REMAINS A SERIOUS CONCERN.
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE TALKING
MAKING CHANGES. TO MEDICARE AND
SOCIAL SECURITY --
AND WE THINK ABOUT THE LAST --
THIS LAST SESSION THE LAST
ALMOST TWO YEARS --
IT'S BEEN.
ELDERLY WITH DISABILITIES
COMMUNITIES AND OUR CARE GIVER
COMMUNITIES.
AND WE DON'T REALLY HAVE.
A SYSTEM IN PLACE.
THAT UNDERSTANDS THE
SENSITIVITIES OF THIS COMMUNITY
IS A COMMUNITY THAT IS GROWING.
IT IS A COMMUNITY THAT IS
DEALING WITH UNIQUE CHALLENGES
THAT WE HAVEN'T BEEN HONEST
ENOUGH TO ADDRESS IN THE PAST.
AND IT IS A COMMUNITY THAT IS
CHANGING.
AND WE HAVE TO BE HONEST ABOUT
HOW WE CULTURALLY CARE FOR ALL
KINDS OF ELDERS.
WE HAVE TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT AN HOUR SUPPORTING OUR
CARE GIVER COMMUNITY.
WE HAVE TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE WE ARE
PUTTING.
OUR SENIORS AND MAKING SURE THAT
THE PLACES THAT WE ARE PUTTING
THEM ARE SAFE.
AND THAT THEY ARE PLACES THAT WE
CAN AFFORD.
THERE IS NO MORE UNDIGNIFIED WAY
TO AGE THEN BE FORCED TO POVERT.
IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU'RE GETTING THERE THAT YOU
DESERVE.
SO I AM THANKFUL FOR ALL OF YOU
ALL FOR CONTINUE COME OUT AND
TALK ABOUT THESE ISSUES AND YOUR
TESTIMONY.
YOUR EXPERIENCES PRACTITIONERS
WILL CONTINUE TO GUIDE AND
INFORM THIS COMMITTEE AND I KNOW
WILL CONTINUE TO EMPOWER OUR
CHAIR AS DO THIS IMPORTANT WORK
SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
AT THE YOU SEE WHY I AM SO
EXCITED TO HAVE HER --
COMPASSIONATE LEADERSHIP AS PART
OF OUR THE PURPOSE OF THIS
HEARING IS.
TO REIMAGINE THE OLDER
CALIFORNIANS ACTON AND LOOK AT
WAYS IT SHOULD BE EXPANDED TO
TRULY REFLECT ALL THE SERVICES
CALIFORNIA SENIORS TRULY NEED.
AS WE EXPLORE WAYS PROVIDE
BETTER COORDINATE THOSE SERVICE.
ENACTED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO
OH CA.
AUTHORIZED CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC
PROGRAM HAVING OLDER ADULTS IN
THEIR HOMES COMMUNITY.
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY VILLAGES
AS AMENDED THOSE HERE SEVERAL
TIMES REFLECT THE CHANGE IN
POPULATION AND AGING SERVICE
DELIVERY NEEDS.
WE'LL HEAR ABOUT IN GREATER
DETAIL FROM OUR PANEL.
I THINK WE CAN ALL WITH THE
CURRENT LEVEL SERVICES FOR
SENIORS --
AS AS JUST REFERRED TO BY THE
SUMMER CATALOGUE OF A IS AN
INADEQUATE.
AND THAT THE STATE BIRDS ARE NOT
WELL DIRECTED.
NOT AS WELL DIRECTOR RECORDED AS
THEY COULD BE ESPECIALLY GIVEN
THE THE DIVERSE GROUP OF OF
LOCAL.
THE FOLKS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL I
THINK THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
GREATER NATION --
IT IS CALIFORNIANS ACT IN A WAY
THAT REFLECTS OUR CURRENT
REALITIES AND THAT WE DO IT IN
SUCH A WAY THAT IS FLEXIBLE
ENOUGH TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE RAPIDLY AGING
POPULATION.
WHILE ENSURING THAT OUR SENIORS
GET ALL THE SERVICES THAT THEY
NEED AND DESERVE IT SO I THINK
ABOUT THOSE ARE GOALS THAT.
I THINK EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM
HAS BEEN WORKING ON AND FOR MANY
YEARS IN THEIR OWN WAY AND I
THINK THE LAST COUPLE YEARS WE
REALLY SEEN --
THE THE WORK OF BOTH FROM THE
STATE START WORKING WITH MY WOR-
COORDINATION AT A AND BETTER
STRATEGY ANOTHER AND IT'S NOT
SOMETHING WE CAN CERTAINLY BUILD
UPON.
AND SO --
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND GET
STARTED IS THE THIS IS GOING TO
GO -- IN
TILL NOON --
AND SO WE CAN I GET A LOT OF
INFORMATION.
OVER THE NEXT HOUR OR SO.
AND SOME BRAKE SIDE ABOUT THAT
AND TO START OFF THIS IS ALWAYS
IMPORTANT.
SPEAK ON HISTORIC OVERVIEW.
AND I'M VERY EXCITED TO IT AND
TO TO HAVE WITH US LARA CONNELLY
THE DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
BOARD DEPARTMENT OF AGING IS
BEEN.
A WONDERFUL PARTNER IS SOMEONE I
KNOW THAT IS COMMITTED. TO THE
WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE IN
TERMS OF FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
NEXT STEPS OFF A NEW GOVERNOR
COMING AND WHAT HAVE YOU WHAT
CAN WE DO NOW.
IN PREPARING FOR THE MONTHS
AHEAD AND REALLY FOR THE YEARS
AHEAD AS WE LOOK AT THE NEEDS
ARE GREAT SO I PRESS LIKE PAST
RECTOR CONNELLY --
IF SHE COULD --
BUT MADE FROM THE PODIUM --
AS TO HER PERSPECTIVES --
THAT WE BEGIN THE HEARING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE TODAY I HAVE BEEN TASKED
WITH A VERY VERY VERY BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF IN FACT --
THIS WILL PROBABLY HISTORICALLY
BE THE FASTEST OVERVIEW THE
OLDER CALIFORNIA'S ACT YOU'VE.
EVER SEEN BUT JUST TO LAY THE
CONTEXT FOR THE DISCUSSION TODA-
AND FIVE I WILL JUST --
KEEP THIS AT A VERY HIGH LEVEL.
AND THERE AND I HAVE SLIDES SO
[INAUDIBLE]
MY THE BEST AT THAT.
TIME.
THAT.
ROUTE MICROPHONE MOVE AROUND IF
THERE'S A MORE CONVENIENT PLACE
FOR YOU TO STAND OR SIT.
I NEED TO BE THERE [INAUDIBLE]
WELL.
RIGHT NOW IT'S IT'S AN SENIOR
CAN HAVE SO IT'S NOT
[INAUDIBLE]
THE SOMEBODY FOR THE LAPTOP
.
WITH.
THE OLDER CALIFORNIANS ACT
REALLY NEEDS SEEN IN CONTEXT OF
THE FEDERAL OLD AMERICAN SOUTH
AND SO LET ME JUST REALLY REALLY
BRIEFLY SPEAK TO THAT.
THE FEDERAL OLDER AMERICANS ACT-
THAT WAS IMPLEMENTED INITIALLY
IN NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE DEFINES
THE FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
RULES FOR ADMINISTERING THE
OLDER AMERICANS ACT PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES.
ESTABLISHES THOSE OLDER
AMERICANS ACT SERVICES THERE
FUNDING FORMULAS AND THE MATCH
REQUIREMENTS THAT STATES NEED --
TO MEET AND THEN IT ALSO
SPECIFIED A TARGET POPULATIONS
AND DATA REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
THAT THE STATE'S MUST COMPLY
WITH. 75% OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGING OLDER AMERICANS ACT
FUNDING COMES FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT --
THEN WE HAVE A 25% MATCH THAT
THE STATE CHIPS AND FROM GENERAL
FUND.
THE OLDER CALIFORNIA'S ACT THEN
IS THAT STATE COMPLEMENT TO THE
FEDERAL HOLD AMERICANS ACT --
IT SPECIFIES.
AGING IS THE DESIGNATED STATE
UNIT ON AGING --
TO RECEIVE THAT HE'S FEDERAL
FUNDS.
IT DEFINES THE RULES FOR THE
DEPARTMENT FOR THE AREA AGENCIES
ON AGING THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING THE SENIOR
LEGISLATURE ADVISORIES
COMMITTEES ALL OF THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS AND THERE'S OF
ROLES AND RESPONSIBILITIES.
IT ALSO SPECIFIES PROGRAMS
ADMINISTERED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF AGING INCLUDING THAT OF THE
CHURCH COUNSELING AN ADVOCACY
PROGRAM AND ALL JUST CAUGHT HIGH
CAP.
ON MULTIPURPOSE SENIOR SERVICES
PROGRAM EMESIS P. AND THOSE FOR
PROGRAMS THAT WERE AND
ADDITIONALLY OUTSIDE OF BILL
THERE OUTSIDE OF THE OLDER
AMERICANS ACT --
THERE NOW PART OF THE BUT
EMPHASIS P. IS IS OUR STATE K.
PROGRAM. ONE OF OUR STATE
MEDICAID PROGRAMS.
AND THEN THE ON THAT JUST SOME
SERVICE SPECIFICALLY FOCUS ON
THE OLDER CALIFORNIANS OUT.
IT ESTABLISHES SPECIFIC --
TARGETING FORMULA. FOR
ALLOCATING THE ERROR AGENCIES ON
AGING THE THE BASE
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNDING THAT
COMES TO US SO THAT THOSE
DOLLARS THE CAME TO COME TO US
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
HOW WE ALLOCATE THEM HERE --
WITHIN THE STATE.
IT REQUIRES THAT THE LONG TERM
CARE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM PERFORM
ADDITIONAL ACTIVITIES ABOVE AND
BEYOND THOSE THAT ARE IN THE
FEDERAL --
PROGRAM.
AND IN. NINETEEN NINETY SIX
ASSEMBLY BILL TO TALK --
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED AS IT IS.
REFER TO TRANSFER THE
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR THE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM ANTI CAP.
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING WE
ORIGINALLY OPERATED IT DIRECTLY
DOWN TO THE LOCAL LEVEL A
TRANSFER THOSE RESPONSIBILITIES
TO THE AREA AGENCIES ON AGING.
THE OLDER CALIFORNIANS ACT ALSO
ESTABLISH TO COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES ARE PROGRAM SINCE
SHOULD JOBS.
THAT ARE NOT IN THE OLDER
AMERICANS ACT --
AND THAT WAS A WIDE ARRAY OF
COMMUNITY SERVICES THEY ARE
STILL ON THE BOOKS.
MOST OF THEM LOST THEIR FUNDING
DURING THE WE'VE A COLUMN THAT
THE BAD YEARS --
BUT THEY STILL REMAIN.
IN THE STATUTE.
I NEXT HAVE A VERY NICE LIGHT OF
THE THREE THREE THREE EIGHT
EIGHT AND EACH.
EACH AGENCY HAS OF IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR PLANNING AND
SERVICE AREA.
OKAY SOME OF YOU HAVE THAT.
GREAT PERFECT.
THERE REALLY BEAUTIFUL IN COLOR.
SO SOME AGENCIES EARLY IN THE
LARGER AREAS OF THE STATE LARGER
COUNTIES HAVE US ARE A SINGLE --
COUNTY AREA AGENCY ON AGING AND
MORE RURAL AREAS THEY'RE MAYBE
SURVEY MULTIPLE COUNTIES --
BUT THOSE OF THE PLANNING AND
SERVICE AREAS.
AND THEN REAL BRIEFLY JUST
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT THE KEY
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES WHICH I
KNOW MR CARRIER CERTAINLY
FAMILIAR WITH --
HUNDRED THAT ARE THAT ARE
DEFINED UNDER THE OLDER
AMERICANS ACT AND YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY --
IN THE OLDER CALIFORNIANS ACT AS
WELL AMPLE INFORMATION REFERRAL.
NUTRITION PROGRAMS PROBABLY THE
MOST WELL KNOWN OF OUR SERVICES
AND THE LARGEST AMOUNT OF
FUNDING THAT WE RECEIVE.
LEGAL SERVICES.
OF SUPPORTIVE SERVICES AND THOSE
SERVICES CAN BE VERY BROAD
RANGING FROM CARE COORDINATION
CHORE ASSISTANCE HOME
MODIFICATIONS TRANSPORTATION
SENIOR CENTERS WHATEVER YOU CAN
SQUEEZE INTO THAT MORE LIMITED -
FEDERAL FUNDING THAT WE RECEIVE.
HEALTH PROMOTION AND DISEASE
PREVENTION PROGRAMS.
CAREGIVER SUPPORT SERVICES IS
ONE OF THE NEWER --
AMERICANS ACT SERVICES.
AND AND AS I MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY THE LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM.
AND IN CALIFORNIA THE THE THREE
AREAS THAT THE LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
THAT IS NOT NATIONWIDE.
IS --
CONDUCTING COMMUNITY EDUCATION
ABOUT LONG TERM SERVICES IN
ISSUES RECEIVING AND
INVESTIGATING. TO DIFFUSE AND
THE COLLECT.
CARE FACILITIES AND THEN WHAT
BURDEN.
TRANSFERS --
EXCEPT.
BY NURSING HOME RESIDENTS.
A MUCH BROADER ROLE AND I THINK-
CERTAINLY IN TERMS OF ADDITIONS
THAT YOU'LL SEE OVER THE YEARS
IF YOU WERE JUST GOING THROUGH
THE ACT TO THE OLDER
CALIFORNIANS ACT.
A NUMBER INSURANCE COUNSELING
PROGRAM WHICH I MENTIONED --
EARLIER ACTUALLY BEGAN IN
CALIFORNIA AND BECAME A NATIONAL
PROGRAMS BECAUSE THE OTHER WAY
AROUND --
AND THEN THE SENIOR COMMUNITY
EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM.
IS ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE FEDERAL
PROGRAMS THAT SEVENTY PARK
AGENCIES ALSO ADMINISTER.
THE MULTI PURPOSE IN SERVICES
PROGRAM WHICH IS A MEDICAL
PROGRAM --
HOME AND COMMUNITY BASED --
PROGRAM FOR OLDER ADULTS WHO ARE
NURSING HOME ELIGIBLE BUT WITH
ADDITIONAL SERVICES --
COULD SAFELY REMAIN AT HOME IS
ALSO IN THE OLDER CALIFORNIANS
ACT -- IT'S
A LONG STANDING PROGRAM WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT.
THE ADULT DAY HEALTH CARE
PROGRAM.
NOW REFER AT SEA BASS A
COMMUNITY BASED ADULT SERVICES.
WE OPERATE THROUGH AN
INTERAGENCY AGREEMENT WITH
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES BUT IT IS NOT IN THE
OLDER CALIFORNIA'S ACTS SO IT IS
IT IS OUTSIDE OF THAT.
AT THIS POINT.
AND I THINK TO IS TO REALLY END
WITH KIND OF THE MOST RECENT
CHANGES --
TO THE ACT YEAH --
MOST RECENTLY IN --
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AGING AND
DISABILITY RESOURCE CENTER IS
FOR IDENTIFIED AND DEFINED IN
THE ACT AS BEING AND THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THOSE --
THAT INITIATIVE COMING TO THE IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH DEPARTMENT
HEALTH CARE SERVICES IN.
A REHABILITATION IS THE CORE
STATE PROP PARTNERS --
ALSO IN TWO THOUSAND SIX IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AGAIN
SPECIFYING THAT ALL OLDER ADULTS
HAVE EQUAL ACCESS TO OLDER
AMERICANS ACT PROGRAMS AN OLDER
CONFERENCE ACT PROGRAMS.
AND ADDED LGBT OLDER ADULTS TO
THE EXISTING SUBGROUP OF AT
GREATEST --
SOCIAL NEED AND TARGETING
PROGRAM SERVICES AND THAT WAS
JUST --
LEGISLATION PASSED THIS YEAR.
AND MOST RECENTLY HAVE ALSO WERE
DRESSED AS I AS I MENTIONED KIND
OF SPECIFIC ISSUES THAT HAVE.
COME UP FOR THE OLDER OF FOR THE
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN PROGRA.
IN TERMS OF ACCESS --
TO TO FACILITY THAN BEING ABLE
TO SERVE THE RESIDENTS THERE.
THE FINAL SLIDE IS JUST A REAL
QUICK OVERVIEW OF THE COMMISSION
ON AGING I THINK PEOPLE THAT
THEIR SOMETIMES CONFUSION AS TO
ARE THEY IN OUR DEPARTMENT NOT
NOT IN OUR DEPARTMENT.
THEY'RE IN THE SAME BUILDING
THAT WORK IN THERE DOWNSTAIRS OR
UPSTAIRS --
WE DO HAVE A CLOSE WORKING
RELATIONSHIPS AND WE'RE VERY
PROUD OF THAT --
BUT THE PURPOSE OF THE
COMMISSION IS TO SERVICE THE
PRINCIPLE ADVOCATE BODY IN THE
STATE ON BEHALF OF OLDER
INDIVIDUALS THEY ARE COMPLETELY
SEPARATE AND DISTINCT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT --
AND THE ACT THE OLDER
CALIFORNIA'S ACCESS OF VICE OF
THE COMPOSITION OF THE
COMMISSION AND THE APPOINTMENT
PROCESS --
AND IDENTIFIES THEIR DUTIES AND
FOR BUT THIS CONFERENCE IS
EARLIER THIS YEAR THAN IT
NORMALLY IS A NEIGHBOR A
SCHEDULE TO ME ELSEWHERE.
AND THEN --
I CONCLUDE WITH SOME.
REFERENCES TO OTHER RESOURCES
THAT OUR WEBSITE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH STRICTER DAY
DO IT YES IS A GREAT JOB AND ONE
QUESTION YOU YOUR OF EARLY ON
MATCH THAT 75% OF FUNDING
FEDERAL 25% --
STATE MATCH WHAT IT ROUGHLY WHAT
IS THAT AMOUNT I DON'T RECALL
THE TOP MY WHO WHO THINK ROUGHL.
OKAY RING ABOUT THAT.
IT WAS YOU GO DO A GOOGLE SEARCH
TO GET BACK IN THERE.
ARE.
YOU KNOW OUR BUDGET IS A PORTION
OF MEDI CAL I MEAN WE BREAK OUT
IT'S A VERY IS COMPLIANCE BUT I
WILL GET GAP THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DIRECTOR AND THEN --
UP NEXT AGAIN TO GET TO ADD ON
TO THIS --
THE CONTACTS IN THE HISTORICAL
OVERVIEW --
SAYS ASTAIRE SIR ASTON HOW ISN'T
SENIOR POLICY ADVISER WITH THE
SCAN FOUNDATION I REALLY WANT TO
THANK THE SCANNED FOUNDATION IS
BEEN SUCH AN INCREDIBLE PARTNER
OF LAST COUPLE YEARS AS WE'VE
BEEN TRYING TO MOVE.
THE BALL FORWARD ON ON ISSUES OF
AGING THANK YOU WELL THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON ASSEMBLY MEMBER COM
LUDWIG.
IT'S CERTAINLY AN HONOR TO BE
HERE TODAY AND TO SPEAK WITH YO-
I AM THIRSTY HOUSE AND AND I AM
SENIOR POLICY ADVISER AT THE
SKIN FOUNDATION OLDER
CALIFORNIANS ACT IN RELATION TO
OUR BROADER SERVICE DELIVERY
SYSTEM.
SOME OF OUR SYSTEM CHALLENGES
FEDERAL STRUCTURAL ISSUES AND
EMERGING POLICY CONSIDERATIONS.
SO ALL STAR WITH THE CHALLENGE
IT'S WIDELY KNOWN THAT MANY
CALIFORNIANS STRUGGLE TO ACCESS
THE SERVICES AND SUPPORTS THAT
THEY NEED. TO LIVE WITH DIGNITY
AND INDEPENDENCE BUT THE PROBLEM
REALLY IS MULTI FACETED AS YOU
BOTH ALLUDED TO IT STEMS FROM A
NUMBER OF FACTORS INCLUDING
SYSTEM FRAGMENTATION.
LACK OF ACCESS TO INFORMATION
AND ASSISTANCE AND AN
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS
ULTIMATELY UNABLE TO KEEP PACE
WITH POPULATION NEAT.
SO ALL IN THE MEANTIME
CALIFORNIA'S OLDER POPULATION IS
GROWING AS WE ALL KNOW IT'S NOT
ONLY GROWING IT'S BECOMING MORE
UNIQUE AND DIVERSE.
WHICH IS ALL THE MORE IMPORTANT
THAT WE DEVELOP A SERVICE
DELIVERY SYSTEM THAT
STRENGTHENED TO MEET OUR
POPULATION NEED NOT ONLY NOW.
BUT INTO THE FUTURE.
SO WHY DO WE FACE THESE
CHALLENGES --
WILL REALLY THE SYSTEM IS OF ALL
KIND OF AS REALLY IMPORTANT
PROGRAMS ALL OF WHICH LARA
OUTLINED AS WELL AS MANY OTHERS
IN OTHER DEPARTMENTS.
ALL THESE REALLY CRITICAL
PROGRAMS HAVE KIND OF INVOLVED
AS THE PATCHWORK --
ACROSS DEPARTMENTS WITH
DIFFERENT ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA
DIFFERENT FUNDING STREAMS --
IN ALL OF THIS ULTIMATELY MAKES
IT REALLY HARD FOR CONSUMERS TO
ACCESS THE SUPER SERVICES AND
SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED IN A
COORDINATED.
STREAMLINED FASHION.
SO MORE AND MORE WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IS THAT THE SYSTEM IS
BEGINNING TO EVOLVE TOWARDS ONE
THAT NOT ONLY LOOKS AT IN
INDIVIDUALS AGE BUT IN
INDIVIDUALS FUNCTIONAL CAPACITY-
AS A CONDITION OF ELIGIBILITY SO
BASICALLY WHAT THAT MEANS IS
THAT PEOPLE OF ALL AGES WHO NEED
LONG TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORTS-
NEED SIMILAR TYPES OF SERVICES
ACROSS THE LIFESPAN NOW THIS
ISN'T TO SAY THAT THERE ARE
DIFFERENCES ACROSS POPULATIONS.
THING UNIQUE NEEDS OF OLDER
ADULTS SAY SOMEBODY WHO IS
LIVING WITH ALZHEIMER'S --
AT THE AGE OF EIGHTY ARE VERY
UNIQUE IN COMPARISON TO SAY A
WORKING PERSON WITH DISABILITY
WHO'S THIRTY FIVE OR FORTY YEARS
OLD.
BUT THE TYPES OF SERVICE CARE
CARE COORDINATION DEPENDING ON
THEIR SITUATION ACCESS TO
TRANSPORTATION AND MOBILITY IN
THE COMMUNITY.
THEY ARE SIMILAR ACROSS THE
LIFESPAN SO WE SEE THE UNIQUE
APPROACHES WE ALSO SEE THAT
THESE POPULATION POPULATIONS USE
MANY OF THE SAME SERVICES ACROSS
THE SYSTEM.
SO WE'RE SEEING A BIT OF A
PARADIGM SHIFT --
THERE'S AN EVOLUTION THAT AS A
SITE IS LOOKING AT FUNCTIONAL
NEED AS OPPOSED TO JUST AGE AND
THIS IS ROOTED THIS CHANGE IS
ROOTED IN A NUMBER OF FACTORS
ONE OF WHICH BEGAN WITH.
THE UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT
HOMESTEAD DECISION WHICH IN.
NINETEEN NINETY NINE FOUND THAT
INDIVIDUALS REGARDLESS OF AGE
HAVE THE RIGHT TO LIVE IN THE
LEAST RESTRICTIVE MOST HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SETTING POSSIBLE
ACCORDING TO THEIR NEEDS AND
PREFERENCES OF COURSE NOT
EVERYBODY CAN ALWAYS LIVE IN THE
HOME AND THE COMMUNITY.
BUT BASICALLY THE SUPREME COURT
SAID IT'S THEIR RIGHT TO LIVE IN
THE MOST INTEGRATED SETTING SO
THIS JUST STARTED TO SET A
STANDARD FOR LOOKING IT NEEDS.
ACROSS THE LIFESPAN IN A MORE
COORDINATED FASHION --
AND AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL WE HAVE
SEEN THIS SHIFT IN HOW THEY
ORGANIZE PROGRAMS --
IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES ESTABLISHED THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR COMMUNITY
LIVING --
THIS BROUGHT TOGETHER THE
ADMINISTRATION ON AGING WITH AS
DIRECTOR CONNELLY REFERENCED
OVERSEAS THE OLDER AMERICANS ACT
PROGRAMS BUT IT ALSO BROUGHT
TOGETHER THE FEDERAL OFFICE ON
DISABILITY.
AND ADMINISTRATION ON
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
AND THIS ADMINISTRATION FOR GOOD
POINT OF COORDINATING POLICY
DEVELOPMENT FOR ALL ACROSS THE
LIFESPAN WITH THE GOAL THAT ALL
ARE ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES WANNA LIVE WITH
DIGNITY.
AND INDEPENDENCE --
SO WITH THE OLDER CALIFORNIANS
ACT THERE REALLY IS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO EXAMINE IT IN
LIGHT OF OUR CHANGING SERVICE
DELIVERY SYSTEM.
OZ'S REFERENCED --
WHEN THE OLDER CALIFORNIANS ACT
WAS ESTABLISHED IN?
NINETEEN EIGHTY IT'S BEEN
AMENDED SEVERAL TIMES SINCE THEN
ALL WITH VERY IMPORTANT CHANGES
AND ADDITIONS TO IT.
ON BUT IT'S NOW WHEN YOU LOOK AT
IT TODAY IT DOES CONTAIN SOME
SECTIONS THAT COULD USE SOME
UPDATING.
AS WELL AS THERE'S NOT MANY
PROGRAMS AND WHO THAT RECEIVE NO
GENERAL FUND SUPPORT.
AND MANY OF SOME HAVE NOT BEEN
IMPLEMENTED TO TO LACK OF
RESOURCES.
SO IF YOU STEP BACK THEN AND YOU
LOOK ACROSS OUR DEPARTMENTS IF
YOU LOOK AT DEPARTMENT OF AGING
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION.
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES ALL OF THOSE
DEPARTMENTS PROVIDE PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES THAT OLDER ADULTS NEED.
OKAY BUT AGAIN WITH VARYING
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA AND THE
CHALLENGE IS THAT THERE'S NO
OVER ARCHING LEADERSHIP STRATEGY
ACROSS AS DEPARTMENTS FOCUSED
SOLELY ON THE GOAL OF HELPING
PEOPLE LIVE WITH DIGNITY.
INDEPENDENCE AND SETTING OF
THEIR CHOICE SO WHAT WE REALLY
NEED IS A COORDINATED BUDGET
POLICY DEVELOPMENT AND SYSTEM
PLANNING ACROSS THE DEPARTMENTS.
AREN'T SO WHAT DOES THIS MEAN
ULTIMATELY IT'S THE INDIVIDUALS
THE OLDER ADULTS IN THE
COMMUNITY WHO ARE STRUGGLING
STILL ACCESS SERVICES.
IN A COORDINATED AND DIGNIFIED
FASHION.
THERE HAVE BEEN MANY CALLS FOR
CHANGE IF THIS WERE EASY TO DO I
THINK IT WOULD HAVE BEEN DONE
ALREADY WE'VE HAD REPORTS FROM
THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION.
BOTH THE THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON AGING AND THE SENATE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON AGING.
HAVE PUT OUT REPORTS FOR CHANGE
BUT UNFORTUNATELY --
NONE OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE
ULTIMATELY COME TO FRUITION SO
TODAY THERE'S A REALLY IMPORTANT
OPPORTUNITY TO CONSIDER HOW TO
ADDRESS THESE CHALLENGES AND
MODERN MODERNIZE THE OLDER
CALIFORNIANS ACT TO REFLECT THE
NEEDS OF TODAY'S POPULATION.
PEOPLE WHO ALL DESIRE THE SAME
THING TO LIVE WITH DIGNITY AND
INDEPENDENCE SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION AND
LOOK FORWARD TO ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR OF I THINK
THAT -- YOU
AND DIRECTOR CONNELLY.
THE FOUNDATION FOR THE
CONVERSATION AND AND WHAT WE'RE
GONNA HERE.
IN THE NEXT HOUR OR SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LOOK FOURTEEN OR IF
YOU -- AND
SO.
WE HAVE A COUPLE PANELS AND A
LOT OF REALLY GREAT MINDS THAT
ARE GONNA BE --
EXPRESSES SOME OF THEIR THOUGHTS
AND ANYONE OF THE COULD PROBABLY
TAKE THE MIKE FOR THE NEXT HOUR
BUT I'M ASKING EACH OF THEM --
TO TAKE THE MIKE FOUR MINUTES
SELECT.
IF -- IF I
CAN I'M GONNA A CALL UP THE
FIRST PANEL AND YOU CAN GO AHEAD
AND TAKE A SEAT.
AT THE TABLE --
I THINK WE MANY ONE EXTRA SEE
THROUGHOUT THIS FIVE YEAH WILL
GIVE A MORE SEED.
AND A REIMAGINE ALL CALIFORNIANS
I CHANGE THE PARADIGM TO SERVICE
DELIVERY PANEL --
WE HAVE --
VICTORIA JUMP THE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
YEAH AGENCIES ON AGING --
CLAY CAN'T LEGISLATIVE CULTURE
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
AREA AGENCIES ON AGING.
NICOLE HOW EXACTLY DIRECTOR FOR
OMBUDSMAN SERVICES A CONTRA
COSTA.
AND SOLANO --
COUNTIES CALIFORNIA ELDER
JUSTICE COALITION --
TOUCH ON A FAST SO CONSULTANT
FOR CALIFORNIA HEALTH ADVOCATES.
AND EILEEN CRUISE DIRECTOR OF
SENIOR CARE SO ONE IS ASK FOR A
THREE OR FOUR MINUTE REFLECTION-
ON THIS TOPIC AND TO KIND OF
AGAIN --
THIS ENTIRE HEARING REALLY AS WE
KNOW FROM THE HEARINGS LAST YEAR
IS A SET THE STAGE ON WHAT WE
NEED TO DO IN THE YEAR AHEAD
LEGISLATION BUDGET WISE.
AND SO THE REFUND YOUR
REFLECTIONS ARE INCREDIBLY
VALUABLE --
AT THIS TIME SO [INAUDIBLE]
OKAY.
QUICK ANSWER YES.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN OF WE RAN OUT
OF THE GYM THIS AND EVERYBODY'S
AT ABOUT ONE SO WE HAVE A
SOLUTION.
WE HAVE A MOBILE APP.
PLATFORM AS PART OF OUR
CONFERENCE.
THE AGENDA IS ON THAT.
SO WE ASK THAT YOU.
GO TO YOUR APPS STORE.
DOWNLOAD ATTEND OF FIVE AND THEN
FOLLOW THE DIRECTIONS FROM THERE
SO PEOPLE CAN.
JUST GO TO THEIR PHONES AND AND
DOWNLOAD THE AGENDA SO.
I THINK.
THE PART.
REPEAT REPEAT ONE MORE TIME THA.
YES.
YOU GO TO YOUR APPS STORE.
AND THEN YOU DOWNLOAD AT TEN TO
FIVE A. T. T. E. N. D. I. F..
I ATTEND A FIVE TEN TO FIVE AT
T..
E. N. D. I. F. Y..
ALL RIGHT AND THEN YOU'D GO TO
THE C. FOR A CONFERENCE.
AND THEN YOU CAN --
FOLLOW THE INSTRUCTIONS FROM
THERE AND PEOPLE WHO AREN'T EVEN
REGISTRY FOR FRANCE CAN DO OKAY.
SO WE GET THAT.
AND THEY LOOK UP SEE THIS IS NOT
YOUR GRANDPARENTS THE FOOT FOR A
CONFERENCE OKAY.
WE'RE DOING THINGS A LITTLE
DIFFERENTLY IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN SO.
WILL BE UP.
AND GET THE EDGE AND IT'S
ACTUALLY YOU KNOW A GOOD SIGN
RENDON AGENDAS IS LIKE WELL
ATTENDED HEARING AND I'M VERY
GLAD.
THAT SO MANY PEOPLE ARE
INTERESTED IN SO --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF A MOVE ON
TO DIRECTOR VICTORIA JUMP.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA-
FOR THE RECORD I'M VICTORIA JUMP
AND I'M ACTUALLY THE DIRECTOR OF
THE INTER COUNTY AREA AGENCY ON
AGING WE HAVEN'T FIRED TERREL
AND REPLACE.
WE DON'T WANT RUMORS --
FROM THE AREA AGENCY ON AGING
PERSPECTIVE ALTHOUGH GREAT IN
CONCEPT AT THE TIME --
THE OLDER CALIFORNIANS ACT
REALLY NO LONGER NECESSARILY
WORKS FOR US SEVERAL PARTS OF IT
WERE DE FUNDED YEARS AGO --
IN STATUTE BUT NOT IN PLACE AND
THOSE WERE CRITICAL SERVICES IN
OUR COMMUNITY THAT WE NEEDED.
PEOPLE --
STRUGGLE TO ACCESS SERVICES
STILL -- AND
THE SILOS AND ALL OF THE STATE
DEPARTMENT'S AND WHERE THINGS
ARE HOUSE AND WHERE THEY'RE
FUNDED.
REALLY DON'T WORK WITH THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT ARE TRYING
TO COME THROUGH THE SYSTEM NOW -
SO ARE A SO FREE ASSOCIATION OF
AREA AGENCIES ON AGING WE'RE
ACTUALLY.
CLOSING A SOLUTION TO PART OF
THE PROBLEM AND THAT'S TO MIRROR
WHAT'S HAPPENING AT THE LOWER
LEVEL --
TAKE AGING AND DISABILITY AND
COMBINE THEM TAKE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AGING AND ACTUALLY
REIMAGINE BUT IT CAN BE AN
EXPAND WHAT IT CAN BE AND CREATE
A DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY LIVIN-
WE DO WANT A MORE EFFICIENT
DELIVERY SYSTEM THAT REALLY
STRENGTHENS ACCESS TO HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES --
SO THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS CAN AGE
AND LIVE WITH DIGNITY AND
INDEPENDENCE AND WE'RE ALSO
SAYING RATHER THAN ADD NEW
PROGRAMS TO THE OLDER
CALIFORNIANS ACT.
REALLY JUST CREATE THAT AS A
FIRST STEP.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FOR YOU KNOW
COMMUNITY LIVING --
WE WOULD ALSO ASK THAT THAT NEW
DEPARTMENT YOU KNOW BE THE
MECHANISM TO STREAMLINING
COORDINATE STATEWIDE HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES THAT WE
THAT WE NEED.
WE WOULD LIKE THIS NEW
DEPARTMENT.
MIRRORING WHAT'S HAPPENING ON
THE FEDERAL LEVEL TO PROVIDE
LEADERSHIP POLICY DEVELOPMENT
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO THE
PROGRAMS THAT FALL.
UNDER ITS JURISDICTION WILL ALSO
ADVOCATING ACROSS STATE
DEPARTMENTS FOR THE NEEDS OF
OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. TO THIS SEND THIS
NEW DEPARTMENT WOULD PROMOTE
COORDINATED POLICY DEVELOPMENT
WITH HOUSING HEALTH CARE.
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TRANSPORTATION
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND
OTHERS AND SUPPORTING INTEGRATED
SERVICE DELIVERY SYSTEM RIGHT
NOW THIS IS NOT HAPPENING
EVERYTHING IS SEEN AS YOU KNOW
SEPARATE SILO.
I'M RIGHT THE POINT WHERE WE
HAVE SO MANY.
PEOPLE COMING INTO OUR SYSTEMS
THAT WE NEED WHICH WERE ALSO
ASKING THAT OR PROPOSING THAT
UNDER THIS NEW STRUCTURE THAT WE
REALLY LOOK AT WHAT.
ALREADY EXISTS WHICH IS --
THE AGING AND DISABILITY
RESOURCE CONNECTIONS AND TURN
THEM INTO NO WRONG DOOR ACCESS
FOR PEOPLE OF ALL AGES WITH
DISABILITIES.
AND OTHER ADULTS AS WELL TO GET
THEIR SERVICES.
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF PROGRAMS
THAT HIM SERRA MENTIONED EARLIER
THAT OUR HOUSE WITH IN OTHER
DEPARTMENTS AND MORE.
WE'RE PROPOSING THAT YOU KNOW TO
CHANGE THAT.
NEW DEPARTMENT BRING OTHER
PROGRAMS ARE HOUSE UNDER.
STATE AGENCIES THAT AFFECT THIS
POPULATION AND HOUSE THEM UNDER.
ONE UNDER ONE ROOF --
WE'RE NOT SUGGESTING THAT YOU
CHANGE THE LOCAL THE SERVICE
DELIVERY SYSTEM BECAUSE THAT'S
INCREDIBLY COMPLICATED BUT AT
LEAST START AT THE STATE LEVEL
AND CONSIDER.
TAKING PROGRAMS LIKE SOME OF THE
WAIVER PROGRAMS AND COMMUNITY
BASED ALTERNATIVES WAIVER.
THE ASSISTED LIVING WAIVER MOVE
THEM FROM DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES TO A NEW
DEPARTMENT --
TAKE OLDER ADULTS.
THAT ARE BORN FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHAB ASSISTIVE
TECHNOLOGY MOVE THEM OVER. TO
AGING OR NOT TO AGING THE
DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY LIVING -
SO THAT WE CAN HAVE A MORE.
YOU KNOW COORDINATED SYSTEM AT
LEAST YOU KNOW A STARTING POINT
TO HOW WE ARE GOING TO DEAL WITH
THIS AND THIS COULD BE THE START
OF A POTENTIAL YOU KNOW.
THE FIRST STEP IN A MASTER PLAN
OF HOW WE'RE GOING.
TO IMPACTS SERVICE DELIVERY.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
A BOLD SUGGESTIONS IN THREE
MINUTES AND FORTY FIVE SECONDS
DONE THAT'S GREAT.
BUT THANK GOD THANK YOU.
NO THANK YOU VICTORIA AND AND
THIS IS PASSED MICROPHONE DOWN.
EVERYONE CONSULTING OR DO THINK
WE'RE A LITTLE BIT OUT OF THE
ORDER IN THE AGENDA BUT THAT'S
OKAY PRETTY WILL.
OKAY HI MY NAME IS TATIANA FIRST
YEAR AND I WEAR MANY HATS TODAY
I AM A CONSULTANT FOR CALIFORNIA
HEALTH ADVOCATES FORMALLY --
THE BOARD CHAIR I AM ALSO AN
OUTREACH COORDINATOR FOR THE
HIGH CAP PROGRAM IN PSA THREE
PASSAGES.
AND I AM A CARE GIVER.
AND I AM A MEDICARE BENEFICIARY.
SO FROM THAT PERSPECTIVE I'VE
BEEN A SPEAK.
WITH HIGH CAP EVER SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN SO I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE TOTAL NEED
FOR HAVING COORDINATION OF CARE
BOTH FROM A A USER A CARE GIVER.
AND ALSO AN EDUCATOR MEDICARE
BENEFITS --
THE HIGH CAP PROGRAM WHICH IS
PART OF A NATIONAL SYSTEM OF
STATE HEALTH INSURANCE
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
IS A COMBINATION OF FEDERAL AND
STATE DOLLARS.
AND WE SERVE.
PEOPLE ANYBODY THEY ARE YOUNGER
DISABLED WITH THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED AND
THEY BECOME ELIGIBLE FOR
MEDICARE DO YOU TO ONE OF THEIR
PARENTS BECOMING ELIGIBLE FOR
MEDICARE.
SO OUR SERVICES IN THE HIGH CAP
PROGRAM AND WHAT WE SUPPORT AS
CALIFORNIA HEALTH ADVOCATES IS
THE EDUCATION AND ADVOCACY THAT.
OUR IS REQUIRED.
OF UNDER THE SHIP GRANT.
AND ON A LOCAL BASIS MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES NEED TO KNOW WHERE
THEY CAN'T GET HELP.
SPECIALLY NOW WITH THE CHANGING
ENVIRONMENT OF MEDICARE
ADVANTAGE PLANS THE PART D.
PLANS WE ARE.
I'VE BEEN TAKEN AWAY FROM OPEN
ENROLLMENT WORK.
AT AT LEAST TWO PRESENTATIONS A
DAY IN FIVE COUNTIES --
TO A COP MY IDEAL WAY OF OF WHEN
HIGH CAP WAS MOVED AS A RESULT
OF AB.
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED AND EVERY
PSA HAS THE OPTION OF HAVING
EITHER A DIRECT SERVICE MODEL OR
A SUBCONTRACTED MODEL.
I HAPPEN TO BE BIAS ON THE
DIRECT SERVICE BECAUSE THAT IS I
GREW UP IN HIGH CAP WITH PSA
THREE SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
SEVEN AND IT IS AN INTEGRATED.
IN MISSISSIPPI CARE GIVER
SUPPORT PROGRAM THE ON EVERYBODY
IS TOGETHER AND ALL I HAVE TO DO
IS IF I SEE A CLIENT OVER
COUNSELORS SEE A CLIENT OR A
CARE GIVER THAT HAS MULTIPLE
ISSUES WE CAN.
IT'S LIKE NO WRONG DOOR.
AND THAT IS WHY IT'S SO
IMPORTANT TO HAVE THAT SYSTEM OF
COORDINATED CARE.
AS A CONSULTANT --
TO CALIFORNIA HEALTH ADVOCATES I
HAVE SPOKEN TO MANY
ORGANIZATIONS THAT DON'T EVEN
KNOW ABOUT HIGH CAP.
AND DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE
BENEFITS THAT PROGRAM WITHIN
BECAUSE PEOPLE DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY DON'T KNOW.
AND WE HAVE TO EDUCATE THEM SO
HAVING A SYSTEM OF COORDINATED
ACCESS FOR ALL OF THEIR NEEDS MY
MOTHER NOW IS EXPERIENCING
SEVERE --
COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENT AND I LOVE
FOUR HUNDRED MILES AWAY.
MY BROTHERS LIVE LOCALLY BUT
THEY DON'T.
THEY DON'T GET INVOLVED IN THAT
ASPECT SO YOU SHE KNOWS WHERE
THEY GO FOR THE ANSWERS AND SO
DID THIS ALL MY COMMUNITY KNOW
WHERE TO GO. TO FOR THE ANSWERS
TO SO COORDINATION OF THE
FUNDING AND ALSO OF ACCESS TO
CARE.
AND PROMOTION THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT AT A CALIFORNIA.
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW WHERE TO GO
FOR CARE UNLESS THERE'S A PART
OF MONEY LOCALLY THAT IS
DEDICATED FOR ADVERTISING.
SO WELCOME YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
INSIGHT LOOKS LIKE YOU HAVE A
BROAD RANGE OF EXPERIENCES OF
THIS ISSUE OF BOTH PERSONALLY
AND PROFESSIONALLY SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATED.
UP MANY LOCAL HOWELL AND THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR OMBUDSMAN
SERVICES OF CONTRA COSTA SOLANO
THANK YOU SUMMER KALRA AND DOVE
FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY --
NOT ONLY AM I AM THE LEADER OF
ORGANIZATION BUT I TO ALSO
RECENTLY WALKED MY BELOVED
GRANDMOTHER TO THE OTHER SIDE
AND HAD TO HELP MY PARENTS
NAVIGATE THE CHANGING.
AND CHALLENGING LANDSCAPE OF
MEDI CAL AND LOW INCOME ADULTS
AND HOSPICE AND HOW THOSE THINGS
WORK TOGETHER AND I COULD SEE
THAT EVEN THOUGH I SEE MYSELF AS
SOMEONE WHO KNOWS THE SYSTEM HOW
CHALLENGING IT CAN BE.
SO I FULLY SUPPORT THIS DUES --
DESIGNATION OF ADMINISTRATION TO
BE LIVING AND WHAT THAT COULD
MEAN I BELIEVE ADDED BEST WOULD
BE TRULY A PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS SUMMER PROGRAMS ARE
DELIVERED AS DRUG SERVICES THAT
WORKS WELL FOR THOSE PROGRAMS.
BUT I BELIEVE THAT WE CAN LOOK
TO THE LOCAL CALIFORNIA ELDER
JUST COLLABORATIVE THEY'RE
HAVING ON THE LOCAL LEVEL TO SEE
WHAT TRULY INTEGRATED AND NO
WRONG DOOR APPROACHES CAN LOOK
LIKE.
SEAMLESS INTEGRATION OF LOCAL
JUSTICE CENTER SAYS AND WE CAN
LOOK TO THOSE PROCESSES TO SEE
WHAT IS WORKING WELL AND TO SEE
WHAT CAN BE IMPROVED.
IN PREPARATION FOR THIS PANEL I
REACHED OUT TO THOSE FOLKS UP
LONGER MEMORIES AND I DO AND
MORE EXPERIENCE AND THEY RECALL
TIMES IN OUR PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATIONS WAY HAD.
TRIED TO ATTEND THESE KINDS OF
CHANGES AND THEY WOULD MEET AND
THEY WOULD THINK AND THEY WOULD
BRAINSTORM.
YET NOTHING CAME OF IT AND SO
THEY IF WE ARE TO MAKE THIS
PROMISE TO OUR LOCAL SENIORS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS I ASK THAT
THIS REALLY BE AN EFFECTIVE AN
INTEGRATED PROCESS THAT WE SEEK
THE INPUT.
OF THE LOCAL NOT ONLY THE TRIPLE
A.'S BUT THE PROGRAMS ARE
PROVIDING ADULT SERVICES WE NEED
TO HEAR FROM THOSE DIRECT SERVER
SOCIAL WORKERS AT THE APS LEVEL
WE DO HEAR WHAT KIND OF DATA
COLLECTION IS LOOKING FOR IN THE
FUTURE -- I
BELIEVE THAT IN ORDER TO
ACCOMMODATE THE CHANGING NATURE
OF SENIOR SERVICES WE ALSO NEED
TO BE REALISTIC ABOUT THE CHANGE
WORK FORCE AND WHAT THAT WILL
LOOK LIKE NOT ONLY THE NEED FOR
CARE GIVERS BUT THE NEEDS.
OF CARE GIVERS THAT WE SIMPLY
CANNOT TRAIN ADDITIONAL CNA IS
NOT RUNNING A PATHWAY TO
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES WHERE THEY
CAN SEEK A REAL SUSTAINABLE LIFE
AND ALLIED HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
AND THAT IS NOT SIMPLY FOUND AN
ONLINE TRADING PLATFORMS WHILE
THAT MAY BE PART OF IT AND I SEE
THAT AS A MILLENNIUM.
WE NEED SUPPORT OF SYSTEMS WHERE
THAT WE ARE ABLE TO BUILD SYSTEM
FOR FOLKS WHO WANT TO SERVE AND
WORK WITH SENIORS AND SEE IT AS
A VALUABLE PATHWAY.
IN THE SAME WAY THAT WE'VE
CREATED SOCIAL WORK SYSTEMS FOR
THOSE WILLING TO WORK WITH
CHILDREN AT RISK POOLS AND
SITUATIONS WE NEED TO CREATE THE
SAME KIND OF INCENTIVES TO BE A
SOCIAL WORKER.
AT THE GERIATRIC LEVEL AND FOR
THAT I THINK WE CAN LOOK TO THE
FEDERAL LEVEL.
BUT WE'RE ALSO CALIFORNIA AND SO
I WOULD ASK THAT WE TAKE WHAT IS
BEST FROM THE FEDERAL MODEL WHAT
IS WORKING FROM AROUND THE
COUNTRY AROUND THE WORLD.
AND CREATE THE BEST SYSTEM
DESIGNING SYSTEM AND SERVICES
THAT WE WANT AND THEN FIGURE OUT
THE PROCESS THAT LATER ON I
ASKED WE NOT BE STOPPED BY
SIMPLY SAYING WE'VE ALWAYS DONE
SOMETHING THIS WAY.
THAT TRULY WE COME TOGETHER IN
THIS ROOM OF INTEGRATED SYSTEMS
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING MY
COLLEAGUES OF HOW THAT WILL WOR.
THANK YOU.
I DON'T THINK THE TWO OF US UP
HERE TO DO THINGS THE WAY
THEY'VE ALWAYS BEEN DONE THANK
YOU FOR SAYING THAT AND AND ALSO
FOR HIGHLIGHTING.
THE THE THE FACT THAT THOSE
CARRYING. FOR OUR ELDERS FOR
SENIORS CAN BE LIVING IN POVERT-
AND AND AND NEEDING CARE
THEMSELVES WE WE NEED TO DO MORE
TO HELP LIFT THOSE ARE ACTUALLY
ARE ARE CARING FOR LETTING.
THOSE THAT ARE IN NEED AND SO
THANKS FOR HOW THAT IN THAT
ASPECT OF JUSTICE AS WELL --
YEAH.
THE I I'D LEAVE.
YES I'M EILEEN KOONTZ DIRECTOR
OF HUNTINGTON SENIOR KERR
NETWORK.
I AM.
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNINGG ME -
COMMITTEE.
HEARING I'M.
MY SITE HAS BEEN IN A SAYS HE
PROVIDER MULTI.
USER THIS PROGRAM PROVIDER SINCE
IN.
EIGHTY FOUR AND I SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND TO A HUNTINGTON
HOSPITAL.
AND IS -- AM
ASSIST P. IS A LONG TERM CARE
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM.
AND I LIKE TO SAY THAT CARE
MANAGEMENT IF I HAD TO DESCRIBE
IT IN ONE WORD THAT WORD IS
RELATIONSHIP.
AND YOU SEE THAT IN THE PICTURE
HERE AS WELL AS I DON'T KNOW IF
I'M GONNA GO THROUGH ALL OF THEM
BUT THE PICTURE HERE ARE.
OUR ACCOUNT MANAGERS --
ARE.
MOST EFFECTIVE IF MAKE CONNECTS
THAT'S NOT GOING TO REALLY GET A
LOT DONE WE'RE GOING TO GET
KICKED OUT OF THAT HOLE PRETTY
QUICKLY IN SOURCE NOT HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE CONNECTIONS.
I'M.
SO THEY MEET PEOPLE WHERE THEY
LIVE IN THEIR OWN HOMES AND
ADDRESS THE NEEDS THAT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE AND A LITTLE
BIT.
ABOUT.
THE PROFILE AND WHAT MAKES
[INAUDIBLE]
IT -- PEOPLE
AGE.
SIXTY FIVE ARE TYPICAL CLIENT IS
MORE LIKE IN HER EIGHTIES AND
SHE'S FEMALE --
OVERWHELMINGLY FEMALE.
I AM LOTS OF DIVERSITY IN.
WAGE AND ETHNICITY AS WELL AS
THE EDUCATIONAL LEVEL
INTERESTINGLY AT MY SITE WE SEE
PEOPLE THAT ARE.
EDUCATED BEYOND HIGH SCHOOL AS
WELL AS PEOPLE I'M IT JUST ONE
EIGHT YEARS OF FORMAL EDUCATION.
I AND I THINK ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT THINGS ABOUT HIM
PEOPLE AT HOME WHO NEED.
HANDS ON HUMAN HELP WITH ALMOST
ALL ACTIVITIES OF DAILY LIVING
AND INSTRUMENTAL ACTIVITIES OF
DAILY LIVING SO YOU HEAR LOTS OF
TALK ABOUT PEOPLE THAT COULD
LEAVE NURSING HOMES.
AND WE HAVE PEOPLE SUPPORTED AT
HOME BUT THESE ARE NOT PEOPLE
THAT LOOK LIKE.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE DANCING
TOMORROW WE'RE GOING TO THE
SENIOR CENTER NECESSARILY
NECESSARILY --
COGNITIVE STATUS IN A ONE WAY TO
LOOK AT IS OUR TYPICAL CLIENT
AND THE MOST COMMON IS NORMAL
COGNITION BUT THE OTHER WAY TO
LOOK AT IT IS MORE THAN HALF FOR
CLIENTS HAVE.
MILD TO MODERATE TO SEVERE --
COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENT AND MORE
THAN A THIRD WITH MODERATE TO
SEVERE.
I'M UP.
AT MY SITE MOST OF OUR CLIENTS
LIVE WITH ANOTHER PERSON WHETHER
THAT'S AN ADULT DAUGHTER OR
WHETHER THAT'S AN AGING SPOUSE
OR WHETHER THAT'S A ROOMMATE
THAT THEY RENT A ROOM FROM.
AND THEN --
WE SERVE PEOPLE ON AVERAGE JUST
UNDER FOUR YEARS.
I'M SO STATE STATE WIDE THE
PROGRAM SERVES TWELVE THOUSAND
OLDER ADULTS AND HERE IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY THAT'S THIRTY
FOUR HUNDRED THIS IS OUR BASIC -
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA EIGHT SIXTY
FIVE PLUS NURSING HOME
CERTIFIABLE.
AND ON MEDI CAL WITH NO SURE
COST THAT'S A PRETTY IMPORTANT
PART OF WHAT WE DO BECAUSE IF
YOU DON'T SUPPORT CARE GIVER.
THE HOME SYSTEM CAN RAVEL PRETTY
QUICKLY AND CHANGE FROM --
BEING ABLE TO STAY AT HOME
SAFELY TO BEING NEEDING NURSING
HOME INSTITUTIONALIZATION.
ARE WE HAVE A TEAM BASED
APPROACHES ARE MODEL OF CARE WE
HAVE NURSE.
AND CARE MANAGERS AND SOCIAL
WORK CARE MANAGERS THAT VISIT.
AND SS INDIVIDUALS IN THEIR
HOMES ASSESS THE FAMILY
SITUATION AND THE HOME SAFETY
AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
AND COME UP WITH A CARE PLAN IN-
COLLABORATION WITH THAT
INDIVIDUAL AND THEIR FAMILIES SO
THAT THIS IS THE PLAN THAT.
EVERYBODY SIGNING OFF ON
EVERYBODY'S IN AGREEMENT WITH --
AND THEN OF COURSE WE
COLLABORATE WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF AGING AND HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO MAKE SURE WE THIS IS
MEDICAID MONEY SEEK OUT AND MAKE
SURE YOU DO THINGS RIGHT OR YOU
GET INTO TROUBLE QUICKLY.
I'M.
OUR STAFF --
ARE ALL AT A COST LOWER THAN
[INAUDIBLE]
I RIGHT AS I SAID THE LONG TERM
CARE MANAGED AND IN A PERSON
CENTERED WAY SO ONE PERSONS CARE
PLAN IS NOT A COOKIE CUTTER TO
WHAT AND THERE'S IS GONNA LOOK
LIKE BY ANY MEANS.
I'M AND THEN WE LINK THEM TO AND
AND COORDINATE WITH THEIR HEALTH
CARE DELIVERY SYSTEM THAT THE
INDIVIDUALS --
HALF.
I'M.
WE ALSO HAVE A UNIQUE ACTS
ASPECT OF EMESIS PETE THAT'S ONE
OF THE MOST FLEXIBLE AND
POWERFUL --
INTERVENTIONS WHICH IS IF WE
HAVE EXHAUSTED ALL COMMUNITY
RESOURCES FAMILY ABILITY TO PAY
FOR SOMETHING PUBLIC BENEFITS WE
CAN ACTUALLY GOING TO PAY FOR
SOMETHING.
I'M TO MEET OUR NEEDS SO EXAMPLE
JUST THE OTHER DAY WE HAD --
WE FOUND OUT SOMEBODY'S --
WATER WAS SHUT OFF BECAUSE THEY
GOT BEHIND ON PAYING THE EIGHTY
FIVE ALL AND IT BECAME A TWO
HUNDRED AND SOMETHING DOLLAR
PAYMENT THAT WAS NEEDED IN ORDER
TO BE ABLE TO KEEP THE WATER
GOING.
AND THIS IS AT NINETY PLUS YEAR
OLD CLIENT WHO IS.
NOT GOING TO DO WELL WITHOUT
WATER IN THE HOME AND SO WE WERE
ABLE TO WITH A RELATIVELY SMALL
INTERVENTION I'M REALLY
RADICALLY CHANGE --
TO HER ABILITY TO STAY AT HOME.
I'M JUST TO GIVE A KIND OF THE
BIG PICTURE.
I'M IN NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE AND
MISSISSIPPI BEGAN IN TWO
THOUSAND I WAS EXPANDED I THINK
ABOUT DOUBLED --
AND IN AND RECEIVED ITS FIRST
TWO THOUSAND SIX RECEIVED IT'S
SECOND AND ONLY.
ONLY EVER RATE INCREASE --
FOLLOWED BY --
THE RECESSION YEARS OF ABOUT 22%
IN FUNDING CUTS.
I'M IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN AND
THE COORDINATED CARE INITIATIVE
DEMONSTRATION COUNTIES --
AND MISSISSIPPI BECAME ONE OF
THE BENEFITS AND SO --
WE WORK MUCH MORE CLOSELY AT
THAT POINT --
FOUR YEARS AGO --
TO TO TODAY --
WITH HEALTH PLAN MEMBERS --
AS AN MSP CLIENTS.
AND ALSO IT CONTINUES TO BE A
WAIVER PROGRAM SOMEWHERE IN OUR
FIFTH YEAR OF THE CURRENT WE
RECYCLE.
AND IN TWENTY OF AND SO IN TWO
CYCLE BEGAN IN IN --
TWENTY TWENTY MISSISSIPPI IS
SCHEDULED. TO TO A HEALTH PLAN
BENEFIT IN THE C. C. I. COUNTIE.
I'M AND I JUST WANTED TO SAY IN
TERMS OF THEIR OLDER CAROL
CALIFORNIANS ACT --
AND THE UPDATING OF OUT IN THE
PROPOSAL.
AND I CAN'T SPEAK FOR MY STATE
ASSOCIATION AT THIS POINT WE
NEED TO KIND OF TAKE INTO THE
PROPOSAL THAT WAS JUST RELEASED
A COUPLE DAYS AGO --
BUT I DO STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
IDEA OF A CORD IN DEBT
COORDINATED THAT WORK OF
SERVICES.
I'M PARTICULARLY PEOPLE NEEDING
TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS SERVICES IN
WHATEVER WAYS THEY NEED --
AND WANT.
AND AND I'M NOT EXACTLY
COMPLETELY CLEAR ON WHAT THE
LOCAL LEVEL WOULD LOOK LIKE --
FOR SERVICE DELIVERY AND SO
WOULD NEED TO TALK IN A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT NAY UNDERSTAND
THAT -- I
KNOW THE INNOCENT PEOPLE PROGRAM
IS A LITTLE DIFFERENT FROM SOME
OF THE AGING PROGRAMS BECAUSE OF
THE MEDIC HOW ASPECT AND JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE WERE.
I'M CAREFUL WITH CELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH EILEEN
APPRECIATE YOUR INPUT AND
INSIGHT.
AND WILL CLOSE OUT THE SPENT
WITH CLAY [INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
I DON'T MIND BEING CALLED YES
THERE ARE SEATS SCATTERED
THROUGHOUT SO PLEASE DON'T FEEL
LIKE YOU'RE OUT THE STAND THE
BACK -- FIND
A SEAT.
MEET MEET A FRIEND AND NEIGHBOR.
THANKS FOR HAVING US AND AND
HOLDING HIS HEARING DOWN HERE
I'M CLAY CAMP EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE SENIORS COUNCIL OF SANTA
CRUZ AND SAN DIEGO COUNTIES.
AND AS THE PROGRAM SAYS I'M
LEGISLATIVE CO CHAIR WITH
VICTORIA FOR CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING AND THIS ONE THING ABOUT
ABOUT THIS PROCESS DATE ACTUALLY
STARTED SEVERAL YEARS AGO AS A
FUNDING EFFORTS.
IN IN THAT FINDING EFFORT IT'S
HOW CAN WE MAKE THE CASE FOR THE
NEED THAT'S OUT THERE AND ALL
THESE GREAT PROGRAMS AND FRANKLY
THE STRUGGLE EVERY YEAR WAS
THERE'S SO MANY GREAT PROGRAMS
WHICH ONE DO WE TAKE TO REALLY
HIGHLIGHT.
DO WE HIGHLIGHT ALL OF THEM AND
THEN HAVE NO ONE PAID ANY
ATTENTION TO ANY OF THEM OR WHAT
TO DO BUT IN THAT PROCESS NOT
ONLY DID WE REALIZE THAT THERE'S
SO MANY GREAT PROGRAMS OUT THER.
BUT WE STARTED THINKING ABOUT
WHAT MAKES THEM CARRIERS THAT
ARE IN PLACE TO STOP THEM FROM
EVEN BEING BETTER.
SO IN THAT CONVERSATION THAT LED
TO THIS GREATER VISION OF WHAT
COULD WE REALLY DO WITH OLDER
CALIFORNIANS ACT IN THAT LED TO
THE VISION WE'RE NOW ON RIGHT
NOW WHICH IS SET AT STOP AT
OLDER CALIFORNIANS ACTOR WE NEED
TO LOOK BEYOND THAT.
AND REALLY CREATE THIS
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LIVING AT
AND I THINK THROUGH MULTIPLE
DISCUSSIONS BOTH IN SMALL
SETTINGS AND LARGER SETTINGS WE
ARRIVED BUT THE CONCEPT PAPER
ALL WORKING ON RIGHT NOW.
SO WHATEVER GOALS WITH THAT
CONCEPT PAPERS TO GET IT OUT AND
I KNOW THAT MOST OF YOU HAVEN'T
SEEN IT WAS ONLY RECENTLY
RELEASED BUT PART OF MAKING THIS
HAPPEN IS WE'RE GOING TO NEED
INPUT.
ABOUT THE CONCEPT PAPER THAT'S
THERE AND VICTORIA HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT TO SEE WHAT PARTS
OF IT WORK WHAT WE REALLY WANT
TO EMBRACE AND MOVE FORWARD AND
WHERE THE PROBLEMS WERE THE
CHALLENGES ON THIS.
WE DON'T WANT SOMETHING THAT YOU
KNOW ALL OF US ARE SPLIT ON
WHETHER OR NOT WE WANT THIS
PEACE OR WE DON'T LIKE THAT
PIECE OR OR NOT WE WANT TO MOVE
FORWARD AS A GROUP.
AND I THINK EVERYBODY IN THIS
ROOM WITH THE KNOWLEDGE THAT.
THE NETWORK OF AGING AND
DISABLED SERVICES ARE JUST VERY
VERY RICH IN TERMS OF QUALITY IN
TERMS OF THE GREAT NEED OUT
THERE AND AND IN TERMS OF WHO WE
SERVE AND HOW WE GO ABOUT THAT
SO.
I'M REALLY ASKING EVERYBODY IN
THIS ROOM TO EMBRACE THE CONCEP.
RIGHT TO THE HEART ABOUT THE
CONCEPT TO TALK ABOUT HOW WE
MAKE IT WORK AND EFFECTIVE TO
ATTACK THE WEAKNESSES WE HAVE IN
THIS SO THAT WHAT GOES FOR CAN
BE SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY
PRODUCTIVE AND THAT WE'RE ALL
EXCITED ABOUT.
AND I THINK EXCITEMENT IS WHAT I
THINK ABOUT MOST WHEN I HAVE
THIS DISCUSSION.
IT'S IS TREMENDOUSLY EXCITING TO
HAVE A COMMITTEE IN IT COMMITTEE
CHAIR THAT'S EMBRACING THIS
CONCEPT AND LEADING IT I MEAN IT
HAS BEEN SO MANY YEARS SINCE
WE'VE HAD THIS KIND OF
LEADERSHIP.
AND THIS POTENTIAL SO IT'S JUST
WITH THE GRAY FULL OF PEOPLE
TALKING ABOUT THIS DISCUSSION
AND YOU KNOW THE THE COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE IS SUPPORTIV-
I IT IT REALLY DOESN'T GET ANY
BETTER AND THIS IS TRULY I THINK
ONE OF THE GREATEST THINGS WE'VE
DONE.
ON AND JUST TAKE YOUR TIME TO
WRAP UP I I THINK --
THE CONCEPT YOU KNOW A COUPLE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE EXPRESSED
CONCERN ABOUT WHERE THEY ARE
GOING TO BE PLACED IN THIS
STRUCTURE.
AND I THINK ALL OF US HAVE THAT
CONCERN AND NONE OF US REALLY
KNOW THE ANSWER BUT WHAT I WOULD
LIKE TO DO IS I'D LIKE TO
ACTUALLY STEAL A SPORTS ANALOGY
IF THERE'S ANY.
GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS FANS OUT
THERE ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THEY TALK ABOUT IS STRENGTH IN
NUMBERS.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE
IN THIS ROOM YOU KNOW WE HAVE
STRENGTH IN NUMBERS AND THEN IF
WE COME TOGETHER OUR STRENGTH
AND OUR NUMBERS ARE SO MUCH
GREATER THAN ANY OF US WORK IN
THESE INDIVIDUAL SILO.
EVEN IF WE HAVE SOME WINS IN
THOSE INDIVIDUAL SILOS THEY TEND
TO BE ISOLATED AND THE DON'T
CONTINUE TO PERPETUATE SO I
THINK WITH HIS GREATER CONCEPT
WE CAN REALLY BUILD ON EACH
OTHER SUCCESS.
SUPPORT EACH OTHER WHERE THERE'S
WEAKNESSES AND LEFT US ALL UP TO
BE YOU KNOW WHERE THE SUN CAN BE
BETTER THAN THE INDIVIDUAL PART.
SO THANK YOU AND YOU KNOW
EVERYBODY PLEASE ENGAGE IN THIS
PROCESS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PLAY INTO
ALL THE PANELISTS AND AND CLAY.
I THINK ASKING FOR FEEDBACK FROM
THIS CROWD YOU'RE GONNA GET IT.
BUT BUT BUT I LIKE TO CALL FOR
UNITY --
BECAUSE I THINK PART OF THE
ISSUE IN GENERAL LEGISLATION I
THINK THAT BUT THIS ISSUE AND
WHEN IT COMES TO SENIORS AGE AT
THAT THAT.
OFTENTIMES GONNA YOU'LL SEE
DIFFERENT GROUPS FOR YOUR
FIGHTING FOR THEIR PIECE OF THE
PIE.
I THINK IS OPINION INITIALLY BUT
IF WE CAN GET TO A COMMON GROUND
AND THE MOVE TOGETHER AS ONE
FORCE -- I
THINK THAT WE CAN SEE GREAT
SUCCESS AND SO THANK YOU AND AND
ALL OF OF THIS MOVEMENT EVEN
BEING OVER THE LAST COMPLETE.
SO THEY AND FOR THAT'S A LOT OF
INFORMATION A LOT OF FEEDBACK
AND I'M GETTING MORE EXCITED
ABOUT THE THE THE YEAR AHEAD --
AND SO WE HAVE ANOTHER PANEL --
OF A REGARDING.
EXPANDING COORDIN
THAT -- BUT
WE JUST HEARD FROM SPOCE SPEAK E
[INAUDIBLE]
BY [INAUDIBLE] FOR CONSUMERS.
THEY HAVE A LIST OF QUESTIONS
AND CONCERNS AND THEY GO DOOR TO
DOOR OR PHONE TO PHONE OR
WEBSITE TO WEBSITE LOOKING FOR
ANSWERS.
OFTEN BEING REDIRECTED OR
REFERRED OR REJECTED.
AND WE URGE YOU TO PUT CONSUMERS
FIRST USE THEIR LANDS TO DESIGN
AN IDEAL SYSTEM.
PICTURE THIS COMMON SCENARIO A
FIFTY TWO YEAR OLD DAUGHTER
LIVING IT AND AS A TRYING TO
FIND HELP FOR HER SPANISH
SPEAKING MOTHER.
CARING FOR HER EIGHTY THREE YEAR
OLD FATHER WITH DEMENTIA IN LONG
BEACH WHERE DOES SHE STARK WHO
IS THETS AND
QUESTIONNAIRES WHO FOLLOWS UP?
THERE ARE SO MANY VARIABLES WITH
AGE INCOME DIZZY [INAUDIBLE]
WE CAN.
THEY'RE ONE OF THE SEC.
RECKON IN IN A IN THE IS TO
PROVIDE CONSUMERS ACCESS TO
ESTABLISH CLEARING HOUSES WITH
RELY INFORMATION --
DATA INDICATES THAT 60% OF
CALIFORNIANS WITH MEMORY
CONCERNS HAVE OR TALK TO THEIR
DOCTOR.
AND LESS THAN HALF HAVE A
DIAGNOSIS WE NEED TRUSTED
SOURCES OF ACCURATE INFORMATION.
AND ABLE TO CONSUMERS ON DEMAND
AND ACCESSIBLE IN PERSON ONLINE
AND BY PHONE --
IN FACT WE PARTNER AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON COMMUNITY
LIVING.
THEY FUND OUR NATION WIDE
COMMUNITY RESOURCE FINDER IT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S AVAILABLE IN
CALIFORNIA IN EVERY SINGLE ZIP
CODE.
ALREADY IN EXISTENCE AND WE JUST
EXPANDED THAT PARTNERSHIP TO
INCLUDE A A. R. P. NATIONWIDE.
THE THIRD TOPIC IS --
WE WRESTLE AT THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION WITH STATION VERSUS
INTEGRATION DO WE CARP
ALZHEIMER'S OUT OR DO WE CARVE
IT IN.
THE ALSO STICK A RESOURCE
CENTERS ARE IN IT.
OUTSTANDING EXAMPLE OF
SPECIALIZATION BUT THEY WEREN'T
WIDELY AVAILABLE IN THEIR HEYDAY
AND THEY'RE VIRTUALLY
NONEXISTENT TODAY.
IF WE TAKE THE RISK OF TRULY
ADOPTING THE PRINCIPLES OF
PERSON CENTERED CARE.
AND WE FOCUS THE NEEDS ON THE
WHOLE PERSON WE CAN INTEGRATE
ALZHEIMER'S INTO PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES AND WE WON'T NEED TO
CARVE.
OUT AND SPECIALIZED AS WE'VE
DONE -- BY
INTEGRATING INTO MS AS PC BASS
AND PACE AND OTHER SETTINGS.
IF WE ADOPT PERSON CENTERED CARE
AND HOPE PERSON CARE
PHILOSOPHIES SO THAT'S AN AREA
WILL BE WATCHING CLOSELY AS WE
MOVE FORWARD TO MAKE SURE THAT
COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENT IS
ACKNOWLEDGED AND ADDRESSED.
IN THE NEXT ITERATION OF THE
OLDER CALIFORNIA ACT AND THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR INCLUDING US.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE ALMOND
HYSTERICAL LAND AND I CURRENTLY
SERVE AS THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF A SPECIES IN THE
SERVICES.
A PRIVATE NONPROFIT.
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
BASED IN SACRAMENTO.
AND BEFORE I TAKE THE HELMETS
ACCC THE SERVICES I SERVE AS THE
TEAM LEADER AGING SERVICES
PROGRAM SPECIALIST WITH THE US
ADMINISTRATION FOR COMING TWO
LIVING WHICH MANY PEOPLE HAVE
MENTIONED.
AND IN THAT CAPACITY I WORKED
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE TELEPHONE
IT UPON OF AGING.
HAWAII EXCEPT IF OFFICE ON AGIN.
AMERICAN SAMOA TERRITORIAL
MINISTRATION AGING ONE NATIVE
HAWAIIAN ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL
AS A THIRTY THREE TRIBAL
GRANTEES IN CALIFORNIA.
SO AS YOU MAY BE AWARE --
DE OLDER AMERICANS ACT WAS
ENACTED BY THE CONGRESS IN
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE IN.
RESPONSE TO THE CONCERNED BY
POLICY MAKERS ABOUT A LACK OF
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES FOR
ORDER ABOUT.
IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT ARE OLDER
AMERICANS ACT WAS A MENDOCINE
WHICH ESTABLISH PROGRAMS FOR THE
PROVISION.
OF NUTRITION AND SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES FOR NATIVE AMERICANS.
IN THE PROGRAM HAS SINCE
EXPANDED TO INCLUDE.
CAREGIVER SUPPORT.
VERSUS BACK IN.
TWO THOUSAND SO ELIGIBLE TRIBAL
ORGANISES IS RECEIVE PRIZE IN
SUPPORT.
IN DELIVERY OF HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES. FOR
THE ALBUMS INCLUDING NUTRITION
SERVICES ANSWER BUT FOR FAMILY
AN INFORMAL CHARACTERS.
SO THE AUTHORIZING LEGISLATION
COMES FROM A SECTIONS.
SIX THIRTEEN SIX TWENTY THREE
AND SIX THIRTY ONE OF THE OLDER
AMERICANS ACT AS AMENDED.
SO YOU LOOK AT CALIFORNIA.
RAZA AN INSTITUTION COLD --
DIVISION EIGHT POINTS I'VE
CHAPTER ONE SECTION.
NINE THOUSAND IT TALKS ABOUT.
THE URGENCY TO REFLECTS THE
OLDER CALIFORNIA'S ACT --
WITH THE MANDATES AND DIRECTIVES
OF THE OLDER AMERICANS ACT.
A IN OUR OF NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE
ITS COMMITMENT TO THIS ORDER.
IN AN OLDER POPULATION SERVED BY
PROGRAMS ADMINISTERED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE WHOLE
LEGISLATION VERY CAREFULLY TO
ONLY.
MENTIONED TWICE ABOUT.
OUR AMERICAN INDIANS DOES
SECTION NINETY FIFTEEN ABOUT
GREATEST SOCIAL NEEDS AND THEN
SECTION NINETY ONE OH THREE
POINT ONE ACCESS TO PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES.
SO IF YOU LOOK AT THE OVERALL
PICTURE IN TERMS OF THE OLDER
AMERICANS ACT PART.
TWO SIX SO BASICALLY WE HAVE
NUTRITION AND SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES.
AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE CARE GIVER
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES.
AND THE PURPOSE OF TITLE
ACTUALLY IS TO PROMOTE.
THE DELIVERY OF THESE SERVICES
UP.
TO AMERICAN INDIANS TO ALASKA
NATIVES AS WELL AS NATIVE
HAWAIIANS.
THAT ARE COMPARABLE TO SERVICE.
I CAN THAT [INAUDIBLE]
THIS [INAUDIBLE]
IS.
THIS CAN NEED.
INDIVIDUALS ONE ALLIANCE AYE
VITAL RESOURCE.
ENTITLED TO ALL OF US SERVICES
AVAILABLE AND SUCH SERVICES AND
MAP IT SHOULD BE PROVIDED IN A
MANNER.
THAT FREE SERVICE AND RESTORE
SERVICE TO THINK IT SEVERANCE
BACKED AND CULTURAL IDENTITIES.
NOW IF YOU COMPARE THAT WITH THE
OR THE CALIFORNIA'S ACT.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE NOTHING
[INAUDIBLE] THREE SIX THAT'S A
EACH.
AGENCY PLAN SHALL PROVIDE
INFORMATION CONCERNING SERVICES
TO OLDER INDIANS.
AND ASSURE THAT AREA AGENCY
RECORD IN A SERVICES WITH THOSE
PROVIDED ON THE PART OF SIX AND
THEN ANOTHER SECTION.
THREE OH SEVEN EIGHT TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY BASICALLY APPLIES THE
STATE PLAN.
WHICH ACTUALLY IS SO DEVELOP BY
THE CALIFORNIA ABOUT AGING.
AND IS SHALL OUR STORE THAT'S
THE STATE AGENCY RECORDED WITH
PROGRAMS.
ON HOW TO THREE WITH PROGRAMS ON
THE HOW.
TO SIX NOW YOU FLIP TO OR THE
CALIFORNIA ACT.
THING IS HAPPENING.
SO IN TERMS OF FUNDING ACTUALLY
AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL.
WE HAVE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED SIXTY
H. GRANTEES. THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
SEVEN OF THEM ACTUALLY --
TRIBAL ORGANIZATIONS ONE IS THE
NATIVE HAWAIIAN ORGANIZATIONS.
REPRESENTING OVER FOUR HUNDRED
TRIBES.
WITH A TOTAL GRANT AMOUNT LOOK
AT MORE THAN FORTY FIVE MINUTE
DOLLARS.
IF YOU LOOK.
REPRESENTING OVER FORTY FOUR
DIFFERENT TRIBES.
AND ALSO RECEIVING FREE ONE
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS.
SO IF YOU LOOK AT THE A NATIONAL
PICTURE OF ALL THE SERVICE
DELIVERY --
IN NINETEEN A IS TO IT SO SORRY-
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THERE OVER
SIX HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
RIGHTS IN TERMS OF
TRANSPORTATION.
AND THOSE ARE THE RICE --
TO NEW SITES TO MEDICAL
APPOINTMENTS PHARMACIES GROCERY
STORES AND A CRITICAL DAILY
ACTIVITIES.
IN TERMS OF HOME DELIVER MEANS
SERVE MORE THAN TWO POINT FIVE
MILLIMETERS TO MORE THAN.
HOUSING HOME BOUNCE YEARS.
AND ALSO THERE'S A COOPERATIVE
XIN. TWO ONE THREE TO SERVE TO
NEARLY.
WHAT ELSE DO? FOUR THOUSAND
NATIVE AMER ELDER.
IN THIS INFORMATION WE FOR OUR
APPROXIMATELY SIX HUNDRED THIRTY
DOLLARS AN HOUR OUR REGION FROM
XIN SENATE AGE DOESN'T SING
CAREGIVERS.
AND IF YOU FLIP TO CALIFORNIA
THE NUMBER SMALLER BUT STILL.
SOME BUTTONS ON SERVICE DELIVERY
TO THE MUCH POPULATION TALKING
OF SO MY RECOMMENDATION ACTUALLY
IS TO ACTUALLY READ YOU AND AN
ACTION IS TO THE THE CALIFORNIA
THAT.
SURE THAT THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
WE REFLECTS THE POLICY AND
PLEASE CORRECT OF THE OLDER
AMERICANS ACT OF DEFIANCE.
AND THE MINISTER ABOUT IT
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT AGING.
AND I THINK AT A MINIMUM.
WE NEED TO AND THAT THE
CALIFORNIA YES PLAN AS WELL AS
THE AREA PLANS FOR THIRTY THREE
ERROR IS AN AGING.
WE INCLUDE LANGUAGE TO FOLLOW
THE POLLUTION ESPERS INSTANCE
SECTIONS THREE WAS SIX AND
ELEVEN TWO THREE SEVEN EIGHT
TWENTY ONE EIGHT OF THE SUMMER
ACT.
OF NINETEEN SIXTY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
FOR EVERYTHING YOU HAVE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DEREK.
YEAH.
YEAH YEAH SCHOOL.
GOOD TO MAKE SURE THAT LIKE.
THAT'S VERY I LIKE THAT
[INAUDIBLE]
PLEASE TALK.
THANK YOU.
HEIGHT WE ALSO NEED TO SUPPORT
FAMILY AND FRIENDS THAT ARE THE
BACKBONE.
IN HELPING THOSE OLDER ADULTS
AGE WITH DIGNITY AND RESPECT --
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY
FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION CARE
GIVERS.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND I
KNOW THIS IS A VERY HARD SLIDE
TO READ I APOLOGIZE BUT
EVERYBODY HAS.
THINGS I'LL JUST GO OVER THE
HIGHLIGHTS BUT AS WE KNOW THESE
INFORMAL.
PAID FAMILY CARE GIVER IN
CALIFORNIA.
LARGELY EMAIL THAT CHANGES ABOUT
FORTY SEVEN BUT 40% ARE MEN.
AND NOT OF SAYING.
WE ARE ACTUALLY IT WHAT IS THE
PROPER THING IS MOST OF ONE OUT
OF THE FOUR CHARACTERS HAS BEEN
IN BETWEEN NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE
AND NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN THAT
MEANS THERE BETWEEN.
TWENTY TWO AND THIRTY SEVEN YEAR
OLD.
AT THESE ARE KIDS GIVERS THAT
TRIED TO BALANCE BOTH THEIR
EARLY CAREERS.
SCHOOL.
PARENTHOOD AND AARON OR A
GRANDPARENT OR OTHER CLOSE
RELATIVE --
ONCE ACT FOR FAMILY CARE GIVERS
HAS BEEN SOMETHING THAT HAS NOT
REALLY BEEN ALL ADDRESSED AND
LOOK AT OF MANY TIMES THE CALL
US. FOR THE FANS ARE NOT BLEED
TRIVIAL AND FOR THE CARE GIVERS
WHILE PEOPLE.
DO THIS OUT OF LOVE AND WE OFTEN
SAID THIS IS A FAMILY AFFAIR.
THERE IS SOME RESPONSIBILITY I
THINK IN OUR SYSTEM EIGHTY TO
HELP OUT AS IF YOU LOOK AT HERE.
ARE THE BACKBONE OF THE LONG
TERM CARE SYSTEM.
AND IN RETURN WHAT HAS.
CALIFORNIAN WOULD HAVE BEEN
GIVEN BACK TO THE SYSTEM FOR
FAMILY CAREGIVERS.
ASIDE A PART FOR THE PERSON.
PORT SO. ONE PROGRAM THAT.
HAS BEEN IN SALEM.
HAS BEEN THE STATE CALIPHATE YE.
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT UP HAS
BEEN THE CALIFORNIA CARE GIVER
RESOURCE CENTER.
WHICH IS A THE WAY OF PROVIDING.
INDIVIDUALIZED SERVICES FOR OR
CALIFORNIA CARE GIVERS HOWEVER.
AND THEY ALSO PARK VERY COOL
SLEEVE THE OLD AMERICA ACT TAKE
THE THIRTY PROP.
WHICH IS OUT SIGNED AFTER OUR
PROGRAMMING CALIFORNIA WITH THE
MODEL SO WE'LL BE THE FIRST TO
RECOGNIZE THE CARE GIVER NEEDED
SOMETHING SEPARATE IN A POP.
UP AND PART OF THAT COURT NATION
HELPS TO BREAK DOWN THOSE SILOS
AND FRAGMENTATION FOR KICK
EVERITT BY PROVIDING A LOT OF
THE DIRECT SERVICE IS AN
INDIVIDUALIZED SERVICES LIKE
SUPPORT GROUP.
RESPITE CARE CAL LANE LEGAL
FINANCIAL AID.
EDUCATION.
AND INTO THE LIGHT MANNER HERE
AS YOU.
SAID IN AN IT FOR THE LAST
HEARING WE ACTUALLY HAVE SOME
VERY STRONG RECOMMENDATION.
THEY CAME OUT OF THE RECENT
CALIFORNIA ASK FIRST ON FAMILY
CARE.
THESE RECOMMENDED ACTIONS OF
ALLOW FOR A LOT OF BILLS SMALL
AND LARGE LEGISLATIVE ARE YOUR
TWO OF ONE THING THAT WE
WOULDN'T.
LEE RIGHT MAN WE LOOK AT WHAT
THINKING CALIFORNIA'S.
HELP FOR FAMILY GIVERS IS THE
TERM OR NOT AS IN STANDARD IS
EVERS SAYS. TO SEPARATE AND
APART FROM.
THE ARE LINKED TO WITH THE REBEL
AND WILL BEGIN TO HELP PEOPLE
RECOGNIZE THAT THE FAMILY
MEMBERS MOST PEOPLE DON'T.
CARE.
THEIR DAUGHTER.
THEIR SPOUSES.
THERE FOR AND AND PART OF ALSO
MEANS THAT WE NEED TO LOOK AT
EVEN THINGS LIKE AWARENESS
CAMPAIGN IN CALIFORNIA.
NEED TO QUIT CARE GIVERS WITH
VERY EASY AND DECIBEL
INFORMATION TRADING IT'S REALLY.
TAKEN UP SO CULTURALLY COMPETENT
AT ELEVEN THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
USE THAT INFORMATION.
WE ARE TOLD OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE
INTEGRATE CARE GIVERS TO THE
HOSPITAL SAYS.
AND SUPPORT THEM IN NAVIGATING
THEY CAN CONTINUE IN THERE ARE
GIVING THIS WHICH MEANS WE DO
HAVE TO PRINT IT.
PROGRAMS OLDER IT IS AN OPTION
WE ALSO NEED TO LOOK INCREASE
FUNDING FOR THE SYSTEM THAT HAS
BEEN AROUND FOR OVER THIRTY
YEARS.
ON THE RECEIPT TO SET THREE CUT
IT HAS NOT COME BACK.
BUT THE HELP RENOVATE.
NOT WOULD YOU TRY TO CHANGE THE
SYSTEM WANTED HAND SYSTEM FOR
THE CAT POINT A CARE GIVER
RESOURCE SECTORS SO THAT THEY
CAN BEGIN TO MODERN EYES AND A
DEBT. TO THE IT IS ONE OF THE
REACH NG DYNAMIC AND DIVERSE
KEPT GIVING ELATION.
HEARING CALIFORNIA WE WANT TO BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS SPECIFIC NEEDS
POPULATION SLIGHT MELANIE.
HERE GET TO OUR S. LOW ARE OLDER
A CARE GIVERS THAT ARE.
NOW IS WE HAVE EIGHTY YEAR OLDS
CARING FOR A HUNDRED YEARS.
PEOPLE.
THEY NEED REALLY A LOT OF
SUPPORT SO IF WE COULD LOOK AT
THE HOW DO I N!N SUPPORT.
THE PROVIDE US IN CALIFORNIA.
AB.
GIVE FIFTY INSTANT.
HAVE YOU BET THAT THEY'VE PUT IN
THAT WOULD BE WONDERFUL.
THANK YOU [INAUDIBLE]
Q. VERY TINA MILLS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTER SEE IF I'LL SEE.
I'VE BEEN WORKING AND I
COMMUNITY FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS.
SEE IF I'LL SEE IS A STATE WIDE
FOR SHIP ASSOCIATION MADE UP OF
TWENTY ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S
TWENTY EIGHT INDEPENDENT LIVING
CENTER.
OUR MISSION IS INCREASING ACCESS
AND EQUAL OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES OF ALL AGES BY
BUILDING THE CAPACITY OF
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS. FOR
OVER FORTY FIVE YEARS IOC'S HAD
BEEN NEATLY POSITION TO PROVIDE
CRITICAL PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
TO PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
THROUGH INVALUABLE PEER MODEL
APPROACH THAT ALLOWS THOSE IN
NEED OF SERVICES. TO BENEFIT
FROM PROVIDERS WHO HAVE LIVED
EXPERIENCES.
THERE ARE OVER FIVE HUNDRED I'LL
SEIZE ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
UNDER THE REHABILITATION ACT AND
MOSTLY MOST RECENTLY THE
WORKFORCE INNOVATION AND
OPPORTUNITIES ACT.
I'LL CAESAR RATED.
I'D INDIVIDUAL ASSISTANCE CHANGE
AT EIGHT FOR ALL.
PENDANT LIVING SKILLS TRAINING
[INAUDIBLE]
YOUR SUPPORT.
OUR NEWEST FEDERAL SERVICE
TRANSITION AND DIVERSION.
AND IN ADDITION TO THOSE FEDERAL
MANDATES CALIFORNIA ALSO --
PUSHES US TO PROVIDE PERSONAL
ASSISTANT SERVICES.
ASSISTIVE TECHNOLOGY AND HOUSING
SERVICES.
YOU CAN SEE SOME OF THE
DUPLICATION OF SERVICES ACROSS.
SOME OF THE PROGRAMS I HAVE.
PRESENTED TODAY.
THE INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS
PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL ARRAY OF
SERVICES BASED ON OTHER FUNDING
SOURCES FOR EXAMPLE SOME OFFER
HOME MODIFICATION SERVICES. TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO WHAT AGE IN
PLACE FIRST IN THEIR HOME AFTER
ACQUIRING A DISABILITY EITHER
TEMPORARY OR PERMANENT.
SEE IF I'LL SEE SUPPORTS THE
REIMAGINE EIGHT AT THE OLDER
CALIFORNIANS ACT CHANGING THE
PARADIGM OF SERVICE DELIVERY
CONCEPT PAPER.
IN OUR EXPERIENCE THE
COORDINATED SERVICE DELIVERY
PROVIDED THROUGH THE EXISTING
AGING AND DISABILITY RESOURCE
CONNECTIONS HAS GIVEN
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS AND
AREA AGENCIES ON AGING.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PARTNER WITH
EACH OTHER OF INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES REGARDLESS OF AGE
WHO ARE SIMPLY WORKING AND
HAVING A LONG TERM SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS. TO MAINTAIN SELF
SUFFICIENCY AND HIGH QUALITY OF
LIFE.
ABOUT HALF OF SEAT FILED SEIZE
MEMBERSHIP IS WORKING TOWARDS
BECOMING AN EIGHTY YEAR SEE OR
IS HE CONSIDERED A DESIGNATED
EIGHT YEARS HE BY THE STATE.
IN VERY RECENT YEARS SEE IF I'LL
SEE AND SEE FOR A WORK CLOSELY
TO ESTABLISH THE STATEWIDE ADC
ADVISORY COMMITTEE WHICH WORKS
TO STRENGTHEN AN INCREASE.
HERE SEE MODEL.
BUT ALSO BRINGS TOGETHER THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING AND WOOD
TATIAN TO BREAK DOWN THE
DEPARTMENT SILOS AND FURTHER
COLLABORATE.
ON IT TIONAL SERVICES NEEDED.
THE POSITIVE IMPACT MADE BY A
DISEASE HAS POSITIONED EIGHTY
YEARS SEE A FILE SEE. TO FURTHER
THE SYSTEMATIC CHANGE BY WORKING
PORTS AND NO WRONG DOOR SYSTEM
BY.
TWENTY TWO SEE IF I'LL SEE
ESTABLISH THE NO WRONG DOOR
WORKGROUP TO ASSIST IN LEADING
THESE EFFORTS.
THE VISION OF THE WORK GROUP IS
TO CREATE.
SORRY QUALITY AND ACCESS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS SEEKING LONG TERM
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS.
OUR PURPOSE IS TO IMPLEMENT A NO
WRONG DOOR SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA
USING COMMUNITY BASED SOLUTIONS
LIKE INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS
AND EIGHTY YOUR SEATS. TO CREATE
A WORKING GROUP THAT ENSURES
THAT THE VOICES OF PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES ACROSS THE LIFESPAN
ARE PART OF THE PLAN IN DECISION
MAKING PROCESS.
STREAMLINED L. TSS ACCESS USING
A NO WRONG DOOR FRAMEWORK.
WE BELIEVE THE KEY ELEMENTS AND
BY ANY.
MOVES AND NO WRONG DOOR SYSTEM
FOR IN CALIFORNIA.
INCLUDING STATE GOVERNANCE AND
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT.
STREAMLINED ELIGIBILITY FOR
PUBLIC EFFECTIVE PUBLIC OUTREACH
AND COORDINATION OF REFERRALS.
AND ABILITY TO PROVIDE PERSON
CENTERED COUNSELING.
CALIFORNIA'S DISABILITY AND
AGING COMMUNITIES DESERVEF ANY S
SYSTEM.
CHANGING THE PARADIGMS OF
SERVICE DELIVERY AND MOVING
TOWARD THE WHITE.
ON THE LIVING OVER.
CALIFORNIA EFFICIENT CAN
RESEARCH CENTER BLIGHTED WITH
THE EATEN CONSISTENCY.
LET THE ATSC SERVE AS A MODEL OF
WHAT IS POSSIBLE FOR ALL OF US
AS WE BECOME.
OR AGENCY DISABILITY.
IT CRITICAL THAT WE WORK
TOGETHER AND THE SILENCE OF
SERVICES AND POSITION OURSELVES
TO APPLY AND ACCEPT.
FEDERAL NO WRONG DOOR FINDING IT
BECOMES AVAILABLE AGAIN IN THE
FUTURE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
DEFINITELY AGREE --
THAT WHEN YOU DO MORE TO SUPPOR.
INDEPENDENT A CENTERS AND AND TO
SOME OF THE OTHER COMMENTS --
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THERE'S NO
MENTION OF CARE GIVERS AND THE
OLDER CALIFORNIANS ACT AND SO I
THINK THAT.
THIS REIMAGINING IS AND AND
MODERNIZING IS ALSO A
RECOGNITION.
OF THE RE THE THE THE ACTUAL
REALITY THAT SO MANY CARE GIVERS
SO MANY FAMILIES ARE FACING AND
MANY TIMES IN SILENCE.
BECAUSE THEY SEE IT AS THEIR
PROBLEM OTHERS A FAMILY ISSUE IT
IS THE STATE'S PROBLEM AND THEN
THE STATE NEEDS TO BE BE THERE.
OFFICES --
ASSISTANCE AND HELP SO THANK YOU
ALL FOR LAYING THAT CONTACTS
DOWN I MEAN THIS IS BEEN REALLY
HELPFUL FOR ME AND WE DO HAVE.
NOT TOO MUCH TIME --
IF THERE IS ANYONE THAT DOES
HAVE -- ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT --
WILL RESTRICTED JUST TO A A
MINUTE OR SO AND AND TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT --
FOR FIVE OR SIX MINUTES --
IF THERE IS ANYONE THAT HAS.
A BURNING COMMENT OR QUESTION.
HI I'M TO DESTROY EACH --
I WAS THE DIRECTOR DEVELOPMENT
FOR THESE HIS CENTER IN
LONGEVITY.
AND THE DIVISION OF GERIATRICS
FROM NINE AND A HALF YEARS --
I WOULD JUST GIVE YOU A COUPLE
MINUTES OF PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
WITH THIS --
WITH OLDER ADULTS BECAUSE I
THINK THAT IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE UNDERSTAND THE HUMANITY
THAT'S INVOLVED HERE --
AS I SPEAK MY FATHER IS
CURRENTLY UNDERGOING AN
EMERGENCY PROCEDURE.
BECAUSE THE JEWISH OF THE AGING
WHERE HE IS AT REALLY CARE FOR
HIM.
AND SO WE'RE HOPING THEY WILL BE
ABLE TO SAVE HIS LEG.
OF THIS MORNING --
I NEVER THOUGHT MY PARENTS
NINETY TO NINETY FOUR WOULD
EXPERIENCE A KIND OF ABUSE AND
NEGLECT THAT I'M SEEING.
AND I AM DOING MY BEST TO RESENT
IT IT'S THE CHOICE EISENBERG HE
FOR MEDICAL CENTER OF THE LOS
ANGELES JUSHIN FOR THE AGING AND
SEE THAT.
SPOKE WITH OVER SIXTY FOUR
GOVERNMENT REGULATORY AND SENIOR
RELATED AGENCIES AND PEOPLE --
MY PARENTS HAVE TO CHANGE
NURSING HOMES TOGETHER.
BECAUSE AFTER SIXTY EIGHT YEARS
OF MARRIAGE.
SEPARATING THEM WOULD KILL THEM.
I'M ON MANY WAITING LISTS
HOSPITALS CAN ONLY MOVE THE
PATIENT ACTUALLY IN THEIR
HOSPITAL.
WHICH MEANS THAT THEY CANNOT
MOVE THE SPOUSE AT THE SAME TIM.
AND I CANNOT FIND A NURSING HOME
THAT WILL TAKE TWO PEOPLE.
WHO ARE ON MEDICARE?
MEDICAID OUT TOGETHER --
THE HOSPITAL DOCTORS RECOMMENDED
REMOVING PARENTS IN THE JEWISH
HOME -- I'M
TOLD THAT THE HOME IS BEEN
REPORTED FOR ABUSE AND NEGLECT
OF MY PARENTS BY UCLA MEDICAL
CENTER.
SANTA MONIC UCLA MEDICAL CENTER
WEST LOS ANGELES VETERANS
ADMINISTRATION HOSPITAL.
AND NORTHRIDGE HOSPITAL.
THEY'VE ALSO BEEN TARZAN ANOTHER
NEIGHBORING HOSPITALS --
THE HOME HAS A VERY ACTIVE
BUILDING PROGRAM FOR EXPENSIVE
HOUSING WITH MULTI MILLION
DOLLAR BUY INS BUT NO PLANS TO
IMPROVE FACILITIES OR LIFESAVING
SERVICES FOR THEIR NURSING HOME.
RESIDENTS [INAUDIBLE]
I'M.
THE HOME IS THE NINE MY FATHER
NON KOSHER FOOD HE LOVES EVEN
OUTSIDE OF THE KOSHER DINING
ROOM.
NOT ALLOW WILL ONLY ALLOW ME OR
COMPANION TO FEED HIM.
HOWEVER --
HAVING HAD A PART TIME PRIVATE
COMPANION FOR A MONTH.
THE HOME TOLD ME THAT MEDI CAL
WILL NOT ALLOW.
ANY ADDITIONAL COMPANION OR
ASSISTANCE FOR EITHER PARENT.
AS LONG AS A ON THAT ACCOUNT.
SO YOU CAN'T GET ADDITIONAL HEL.
OF FROM THE OUTSIDE.
AT MY FATHER --
WITHOUT HIS COMPANION HAS
RETURNED TO DEHYDRATION AND
MALNUTRITION.
EVEN WITH TO FEEDING THAT THE
DOCTORS YOU SEE PLAY.
PROVIDE AND TO QUOTE AS SHIRIN'S
AGAINST THE CARE THE HOT.
I'M SO THIS IS REALLY A VERY
CRITICAL SITUATION TODAY.
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T MOVE THEM.
THE HOME CAN DO ANYTHING THEY
WANT -- THE
ABUSE AND NEGLECT IS TREMENDOUS.
I'M VERY SORRY INTO THIS AND AND
UP. ONE AT A MY NAME IS IS A
COMMON AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA LONG TERM
CARE OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATE.
I'D LIKE TO DO IS CONNECT WITH
YOU SO THAT.
YES SO I CAN WORK WITH YOU WITH
WISE AND HEALTHY AGING.
PROGRAM SO WE NEED TO WE CAN.
TWO YEARS.
NORTH [INAUDIBLE]
THE WE'LL WORK WITH [INAUDIBLE]
I I I APOLOGIZE WHAT YOU GO
THROUGH --
AND ONE OF FOOTBALL MORE WITH ON
BUT SOME PROGRAM BUT YOU'RE
RIGHT I MEAN THAT DAHLE TO
PROGRAMS ARE TO HELP GUIDE YOU
ABOUT CAN'T NESTLE MAKE.
CHANGES YEAH.
BUT THE THE THE THANK YOU.
FOR EXPRESSING.
WHAT YOUR FAMILY IS GOING
THROUGH I THINK IT'S A?
LITTLE A LOT OF FAMILIES GO
THROUGH A SPECIAL.
WITH THEIR PET WITH THEIR
PARENTS SO IN THE SYSTEM AND I
THINK THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR US.
TO LOOK AT SOME OF THOSE ISSUES
WHERE WE'RE HAPPY TO DO THAT --
IF IT'S GENERAL STATEWIDE ISSUES
RATHER THAN AN INDIVIDUAL UP
INDIVIDUALIZE SITUATION YES SIR.
HI MY NAME IS RICHARD WOLF ON
WITH THE THERE'S GROWING
EVIDENCE THAT THE CARE GIVERS UP
TO DATE TAPE.
HAS UP.
THE REFERENCE.
THE OUR INVOLVEMENT.
BEING MORE INVOLVED WITH THE
COMPLEX TASKS.
BOTH A INVOLVED ALL DAY IT'S
EXPANDING.
OUR SUFFERING EXCESS.
EXCESS A VIA NEGATIVA COMES
WILDLY.
A PATIENT OR ON THE RESIDENT.
RECEIVES GREAT SERVICES BUT THE
CARE GIVER SUFFER MANY TIMES
VERY.
SAD OUTCOMES OR EVEN DEATH AND
I'D LIKE TO HEAR MORE ABOUT THIS
AND WHO WOULD BE MONITORING.
AND FOLLOWING UP WITH.
THESE PARTICULAR ISSUES IN VIEW
OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ARE
PRESENTED.
WE ARE A LOT OF FEEDBACK ON CARE
GIVERS I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT THAT
WE NEED TO DO MORE --
TO PROTECT AND CARE FOR A CARE
GIVERS NOTHING THAT'LL BE
CERTAINLY AN OUTCOME OF THE
CONVERSATION TODAY.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD FOR THE
LEGISLATION AND OR OR BOOK
POLICY BUT THAT'S PART OF WHY
KING.
AT IMAGINE THE ALL CALIFORNIANS
ACTS A INDICATED THERE'S NO CARE
GIVERS AT ALL IN THE ACT AND SO
I THINK THAT.
BASED UPON THE FEEDBACK WE'RE
GETTING --
THAT SHOULD CHANGE AND AND SEE
IF WE CAN.
MAKE THAT HAPPEN IS FOR IN.
HOUSE.
YEAH.
WE HAVE THAT INFORMATION
SPECIFICALLY ON CARE GIVERS AS
WELL AND WILL USE THAT AS PART
OF OUR BACK.
TO IS.
WHAT DOES WILL JUST TAKE ONE
MORE SIN INTERESES TIME --
SAYS WE'LL BE WRAPPING UP VERY
SOON.
HI MY NAME IS PAULA MARGISON AND
JUST FROM A PERSONAL PERSPECTIV.
I AM I WILL BE SEVENTY TWO IN
JANUARY AND I'M TOTALLY BLIND
HAVE BEEN ALL MY LIFE.
AND I'VE WORKED FOR FORTY YEARS
STILL WORK BUT HOPEFULLY
RETIREMENT IS AROUND THE CORNER.
I'M ALSO A TRIBAL MEMBER OF THE
CHOCTAW TRIED.
IT WOULD BE SO FANTASTIC AS I
LOOK AT RETIREMENT AND TRYING TO
REORGANIZE MY LIFE.
IF I COULD GO TO ONE PLACE AND
LEARN ABOUT ALL THE BENEFITS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE. TO PEOPLE
DISABILITIES PEOPLE WHO ARE
OLDER.
HER TRAVEL MEMBERS SO I REALLY
STRONGLY FROM A CONSUMER POINT
OF VIEW SUPPORT A COORDINATED
APPROACH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS A A GREAT
COMMENT AND UNDERSERVED WE'VE
BEEN TALKING A LOT ABOUT
COORDINATION AND THE FACT THAT.
THERE'S A LOT OF RESOURCES A LOT
OF INFORMATION A LOT OF PEOPLE.
THAT ARE OFFERING A SERVICES BUT
THEY'RE NOT ALL IN THE SAME
PLACE THEY'RE ALWAYS COMMU
WITH ONE ANOTHER.
AND I THINK THAT THAT THAT.
HOPEFULLY CAN BE AN OUTCOME OVER
THE NEXT YEARS.
AS AS A STATE.
TERMS WHAT SEIZE COMMUNICATING.
ANOTHER [INAUDIBLE]
SO [INAUDIBLE]
I'M.
BUT MY ASSEMBLY CALLED LIKE TO
MAKE ANY CLOSING COMMENTS.
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME I'LL
JUST KEEP IT REALLY SHORT BUT I
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL --
FOR SPENDING THIS TIME WITH ALL
OF US TALKING ABOUT THESE ISSUES
IT'S INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT TO
HEAR PERSONAL STORIES.
BECAUSE IT JUST REMINDS YOU
REALLY HOW FRAGMENTED AND BROKEN
THE SYSTEM IS I HOPE AS WE
CONTINUE TO DREAM ABOUT.
THE KIND OF SYSTEM THAT WE'RE
GOING TO WORK TO CREATE WE ALSO
TALK ABOUT ARE HOMELESS SENIORS
IN FIGURING OUT HOW.
WE CARE FOR THEM IF WE LUMP THEM
IN HOMELESS BUCKETS OR IF WE
REALLY TAKE CARE OF THEM AS
SENIORS BECAUSE THEY ARE STILL
DEALING WITH ISSUES THAT FOLKS
WERE AGING HAVE TO DEAL WITH.
AND HAVE A REAL CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW WE HOLD FACILITIES
ACCOUNTABLE YOU KNOW OVERSIGHT.
IS JUST A WORD IF WE DON'T GIVE
TEETH IN ACCOUNTABILITY TO YOU
KNOW HOW ARE MAKING SURE THAT
OUR AGING FAMILY MAN.
AND NO ONE WANTS TO TALK ABOUT
THAT.
BUT WHEN WE'RE WHEN THOSE FOLKS
ARE IN PAIN THEY'RE CONNECTED
FAMILIES ARE IN PAIN AND WE
REALLY HAVE A RIGHT AND A
RESPONSIBILITY TO HOLD --
FACILITIES AND GROUPS AND AND
THE COMMUNITY ACCOUNTABLE SO I
HOPE THAT SOMETHING WE CAN
CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
AND AS WE CLOSE THE HEARING A
CELEBRITY NINES WILL BE CLOSING
ON TIME --
LET'S THING VERY POOR MY THE
CHIEF CONSULTANT FOR THE AGING
LONG TERM CARE COMMITTEE I KNOW
THAT HE'S WORKED WITH MANY OF
YOU.
OVER THE PAST COUPLE YEARS SINCE
I'VE BEEN CHAIR CERTAINLY AND
EVEN BEFORE THAT --
AND AS PART OF THIS ON GOING.
PROCESS AGAIN WE WE DON'T DO
THIS JUST FOR US TO GET FEEDBACK
WE DO THIS TO ACTUALLY GET BILLS
MOVING FORWARD TO GET POLICY
IMPORTANT BUDGET ASSN WE'VE HAD
SOME SUCCESS WITH THAT.
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS WE HAVE
SOME BILLS ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
BRING BACK --
WHICH MORE THAN HAPPY TO DO --
BUT AS PART OF THAT PROCESS --
BUT WE'RE PLANNING TO HAVE
ANOTHER INFORMATIONAL HEARING AS
WE START THE LEGISLATIVE YEAR OF
FOCUSING ON THE MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING AND I THINK THAT THAT
REALLY KIND OF HEARING ALL THE
FEEDBACK.
REALLY THAT'S WHAT IT CULMINATE.
INTO IS IS A MASTER PLAN WHICH
WE DON'T.
HAVE AT THE MOMENT THAT WE CAN
REALLY GET ALLOWED TO GUIDE US.
AND THE ALL THE CONVERSATIONS
WHETHER IT'S ISSUES WITH SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES WHETHER IT'S
INDEPENDENT LIVING WHETHER IT'S
GOOD BUT IT'S JUST YOU KNOW BUT
TROUBLES I CARE GIVERS SPACE.
THESE ARE ALL THINGS THAT WE
NEED TO BE TALKING ABOUT AS PART
OF A LARGER --
MOBILE PLAN AND SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO BEING PART OF A TO
WORK WITH ALL OF YOU TO BE PART
OF OF THE TEAM MOVING THAT
FORWARD AND I KNOW AS A MEMBER.
KAMLAGER-DOVE GOING TO BE THE
RIGHT THERE WITH US AND SO I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU SO MUCH
FOR ONCE AGAIN --
BEING HERE I WANT --
TO CERTAIN THANKS THANKS TO SEE
FOUR EIGHT AGAIN HOW FULLY
ALLOWS ALL OF YOU IN IN YOUR
WORK -- TO
STAND THAT THERE IS --
A PARTNERSHIP IN IN THE STATE
ASSEMBLY AND THAT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING IT AND
DOING MORE. FOR AGING COMMUNITY
THAN WE ARE TODAY SO THANK YOU
ALL VERY MUCH